après avoir lancé ce matin le
cyclearique avec l'audition de du
professeur membé nous accueillons pour
cette seconde
audition monsieur Arthur Branca docteur
en histoire et maître de conférence à
l'Université oufouette boan que je
remercie pour sa présence à nos côté et
toutes les couleurs qu'il nous apportent
ma ma veste paraî bien uniforme à ses
côtés en visioconférence nous
accueillons également monsieur Gill Yabi
chercheur et président fondateur de wati
qui est un un f tank citoyen de
l'Afrique de de l'Ouest ainsi que
Monsieur Karim bitard qui est professeur
à l'École normale supérieure de Lyon et
de et à l'Université de Saint-Joseph à à
beyouth le thème reste le même les
sociétés africaines leur transformation
leur relations avec le pouvoir et et
l'extérieur et j'espère que vous pourrez
chacun revenir selon vos prismes
respectifs sur les évolutions
intrinsèques aux États africains aux
société africaine et notamment sur le
rôle joué par les sociétés civiles dans
les grandes transformations qui sont à
l' œuvre monsieur banga donc qui a à mes
côté vos recherches portent
particulièrement sur les relations sur
les questions de défense en en Afrique
l'armée ivoirienne bien sûr et sur les
relations
afro-fançaises mais je sais également
qu'au-delà de ces travaux vous menez des
réflexions sur plusieurs questions
d'ordre général dans le débat public et
vous êtes notamment l'un des
chroniqueurs médias les plus suivis en
en Côte d'Ivoire monsieur Gilles Yabi
qui est en en visioconférence vous êtes
président fondateur de de watti mais
également analyse politique et docteur
en économie du du développement vous
intervenez régulièrement dans les médias
internationaux sur les questions de paix
de sécurité de gouvernance politique et
économique en Afrique de l'Ouest et
j'imagine que vous aurez notamment
accord de nous présenter votre fingtan
qui je crois ce qu'oit comme une
plateforme ouverte de de production et
d'échange d'idées de connaissance et de
formulation de pistes d'action pour
transformer les sociétés W ouest
africaines mais également pour nous
livrer votre regard sur la consolidation
démocratique en Afrique de l'Ouest à
l'heure où les coups d'État se sont
succédés dans la région et enfin
Monsieur Karim Bitar ancienne élève de
l'école national
d'administration vous êtes également
chercheur associé à l'IRIS spécialiste
du Moyen-Orient et de la politique
étrangère des États-Unis nous serions
notamment heureux de vous entendre et
d'échanger avec vous sur les dynamiques
propres aux sociétés du Maghreb ainsi
Messieurs je vous laisse la parole sur
tous ces points et bien entendu sur
l'ensemble des sujets que vous
souhaiteriez aborder si vous le
souhaitez on peut commencer par Monsieur
banga vous avez la parole
ok
d'accord bonjour monsieur le Président
et bonjour chers honorables députés je
suis très content d'être avec vous ce
matin pouvoir euh aborder la question
qui nous qui nous réunit ce jour dans
cette commission de défense déjà je me
réjouis que euh même s'il y a une
vieille tradition de rapport
parlementair sur les relations entre
Afrique et la France mais je me réjouis
que que cette question sorte du précaré
présidentiel et retombe à l'Assemblée
nationale donc devant le peuple puisque
vous êtes représentant de ce peuple là
et et donc c'est c'est vraiment
intéressant que la question aujourd'hui
des relations entre la France et
l'Afrique soit abordé par le bas et par
les représentants du peuple plutôt que
de rester de façon très institutionnelle
et très présidentielle bien euh la
réflexion que je vais vous proposer va
passer en partie sur la sociétés civiles
africaine leur transformation leur
regard et aussi leur leurs attentes hein
face au pouvoir et surtout face aux
relations de extérieur de l'Afrique euh
en gros les les sociétés civiles
africaines à l'image hein de des
sociétés générales en Afrique sont en
pleine transformation transformation euh
liée à la jeunesse du continent on a un
continent qui a un peu plus de près de 3
cas de sa population euh en dessous de
35 ans euh et donc une jeunesse beaucoup
plus euh éduqué instruite éduqué et
surtout beaucoup plus connecté ça c'est
très important de telle sorte que tous
les changement ou ou tout ce qui se
passe dans le monde aujourd'hui euh se
retrouve très facilement euh euh et même
souvent dans les coins les plus reculés
que vous pouvez d'Imagine d'Afrique donc
c'est un grand changement euh par
rapport aux années passées où il fallait
attendre je pense tout le monde avec il
fallait attendre que l'information tombe
et chez des experts et tout et donc
cette ouverture de la jeunesse africaine
et des sociétés civile africaine en
général fait qu'elle est très au courant
et qu'elle s'intéresse de plus en plus
aux questions internationales au rapport
que le continent peut avoir avec
d'autres acteurs notamment l'acteur les
acteurs africains alors qu'il y a
quelques années c'était des questions
d'experts ou des questions de diaspora
de gens qui s'intéressaient aujourd'hui
parler de de la France en Afrique parler
des États-Unis en Afrique parler de la
Russie en Afrique ça se retrouve on en
parle partout dans le continent et c'est
c'est assez intéressant de de de voir ce
changement on parle aussi des jeunesses
mais aussi des femmes hein qui qui font
une bonne moitié de la population qui
aussi qui ont été longtemps euh loin de
ces questions et qui commencent à s'y
intéresser parce que éducation
formation connexion au monde entraîne
cette transformations qu'on peut avoir
dans la société africaine et donc on est
donc sur une vraie transformation de la
société africaine hein des sociétés
africaines j'ai envie de dire chacun
avec ses attentes une transformation qui
s'accompagne qui qui s'inspire des
transformations mondiales et des
ruptures mondiales et une transformation
qui permet justement au au continent
africain de voir tous ces changements et
toutes ces ruptures géopolitiques d'un
point de vue mondial aujourd'hui vous
allez ouvrir tomber dans un quartier
d'Abidjan on vous parlera de ce qui se
passe en Israël on vous parlera de ce
qui se passe en Ukraine voilà et donc ça
c'est ce changement assez important et
finalement cette cette société civile
elle va s'organiser elle va se
structurer euh déjà par rapport au
pouvoir en Afrique hein même euh même
s'il y a une partie de cette de cette
société civile qui peut être inféodé en
quelque sorte au au aux différents
pouvoirs qu'on peut avoir hein il y a
une bataille de sociétés civil souvent
dans les espaces publicques africains
entre les sociétés civiles proches du
pouvoir qui vont essentiellement essayer
de de redonner ou d'amplifier les idées
les pensées euh des pouvoirs mais il y a
une société civile euh au sens propre de
ce thème qui s qui s'attache à des
questions qui s'attachent à la
transformation de la société et qui
s'attache de plus en plus
à la vie internationale au rapports
internationaux qu'on peut avoir sur le
continent euh malheureusement
elle peut être souvent persécuté hein
dans dans dans sa façon de voir et dans
sa façon de de s'exprimer et quand elle
est persécutée elle peut elle peut
porter la responsabilité de cette
persécution d'abord au pouvoir qu'on
peut avoir en Afrique mais aussi à ceux
qui sont vus comme des partenaire de ce
pouvoir et ça assez intéressant pour
pour comprendre la suite de mon propos
qui va arriver et donc mon propos va se
va se va se cibler maintenant sur
l'essentiel de de de notre de notre
discussion je pense comment cette
société civile au-delà la société
africaine perçoit aujourd'hui ses
relations avec le monde extérieur et et
et avec la France et l'Europe et comme
je l'ai dit au début de mon propos à
l'enterme de mon propos c'est des
questions qui deviennent de plus en plus
présentes de plus en plus présentes
parce que euh il y a cette
transformation de la société don que
j'ai évoqué mais il y a aussi cette
connexion entre des problèmes j'ai envie
de dire nationaux qui peuvent avoir des
ou des interprétations internationales
je prends l'exemple par des des des 3è
mandat sur sur le plan démocratique par
exemple on voit très bien que c'est une
question nationale mais qui va toucher
tout de suite parce que les positions
les rapports que que l'extérieur peut
avoir avec un président ou avec un
régime qui va poursuivre son mandat ou
avec un régime qui va être dictatorial
peut un peu alimenter la réflexion
c'est-à-dire on peut aller au-delà d'un
régime dictatorial d'un régime qui qui
qui prolonge euh son temps au pouvoir
pour dire que pour pour arriver à la
conclusion de se dire il le fait parce
qu'il a des soutiens il le fait parce
que le la communauté internationale ou
parce que dans ses relations
internationales il a du poids et donc
finalement cette contestation interne va
avoir une bonne part de son explication
externe euh aussi sur le plan social
parce que face à la face à la pauvreté
face aux difficultés on va chercher des
ressorts des ressorts par exemple dans
le franc CFA pour pour ce qui est du
monde francophone expliquer que tous ces
frein de développement peuvent
s'expliquer par euh par par cette
monnaie en partie ou par le poids
important que vont prendre des
entreprises internationales hein dans le
système économique local donc voyez des
questions euh qu'on pourrait penser
nationales mais qui sont très bien
interprété très bien discuté sur le plan
euh des des rapports que l'Afrique peut
avoir la même chose sur la question de
la sécurité hein notamment dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme
euh quand on voit par exemple euh que
après des années d'intervention ne
trouve pas de changement par exemple on
l' vu avec la présence de Serval et de
barkanan par moment au Mali ça pose des
questions de de de cette de cette
relation qu'on peut avoir avec
l'extérieur sans oublier le poids de
l'histoire d'une histoire très
compliquée he par par ses ombres et par
ses lumières et surtout des regards et
des perceptions qu'on peut avoir sur
cette histoire hein comment les autres
perçoivent ces relations donc tout ça
sont des questions qui qui qui sont
posées par cette société civile
africaine euh euh en attendant de
rentrer dans le fond du débat je pense
aujourd'hui il y a principalement avec
la France il y a des questions qui sont
posées notamment j'ai parlé de la
question du Fran CFA la question du
soutien au démocratie la question des
présences militaires et et de l'usage
militaire la question d'une d'une sorte
de euh j'ai envie de dire d'un héritage
euh qui qui met en position de dominant
et de dominer et souvent même de
priorité je me rappelle quand quand
l'ambassadeur LGBT devait arriver au
Cameroun il y a une un petit TW qui a
été assez intéressant assez repris pr
les Chinois nous emmènent des
infrastructures les Russes de la
sécurité les Français nous envoient des
homosexuels parce que c'est pas c'est
pas la priorité du moment en quelque
sorte on a l'impression que les agendas
internationaux sont des agendas qui sont
imposés et finalement cette société
civile je pense doit avoir un rôle
beaucoup plus important et c'est là
qu'il faut saluer l'initiative de
Montpellier mais au-delà l'initiative
que vous avez aujourd'hui de parler je
suppose que les chercheurs représentent
aussi un parti cette société civile je
pense qu'il faut continuer à travailler
avec elle c'est par elle que peut venir
une bonne partie de la transformation
bien sûr il faut continuer avec le monde
politique avec les les gouverns mais il
faut continuer avec cette société civile
l'accompagner dans cette transformation
dans sa formation dans son résutage lui
donner des outils et d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça je que que je salue l'initiative
de de Montpellier qui était de mettre en
place la fondation de l'innovation pour
la démocratie qui de qui doit
normalement résauter accompagner toute
cette société civile qui s'engage sur
ces questions de démocratie si c
question question d'écologie hein mais
sur d'autres questions aussi et donc ce
sont ces soutiens je pense elle doit
prendre une place beaucoup plus
importante dans la construction de de
cette relation justement la construction
à mon avis doit balancer sur le thème
que j'emprunte souvent de coconstruction
parce que justement coconstruction on
doit pouvoir aborder ensemble et à tous
les niveaux les problèmes qui seront
commun voilà euh construction entre les
dirigeants mais queonstruction aussi
avec le peuple hein avec les sociétés
civiles avec la diplomatie parlementaire
que vous pouvez faire de votre côté mais
il faut que ce soit ensemble que des
projets soient montés en entendant en
entendant les les les les remarques les
critiques et tout ce qu'on peut avoir de
négatif mais c'est ce bloc là qui pourra
donner un avenir à à cette relation
afro-française pour me terminer parce
que je vois qu'il me reste à peu près 30
secondes euh les sociétés civiles
africaines sont en pleine transformation
en en pleine rupture et ça peut se voir
et souvent comme toute rupture ça peut
paraître brutal ça peut paraître abrut
mais c'est nécessaire et la voie la voie
pour construire l'avenir de nos
relations et pour mieux prendre en
compte un la place de l'Afrique dans
cette dans cette relation c'est
justement associer ces sociétés civiles
à la construction d'un avenir
afro-français voilà présenter en 10
minutes peut-être un peu un peu moins
mon mon propos liminire en attendant
d'avoir des discussions en profondeur
merci cher arur pour ce cette
présentation complète et dynamique j'
l'IS presque dire inspirante sur ce
qu'on peut faire ensemble et notamment
avec les sociétés civiles effectivement
on est aujourd'hui dans une démarche
d'écoute et d'humilité vous entendre
c'est pour nous extrêmement
important la parole est désormais à
gilab qui est en visionférence est-ce
que vous nous entendez
oui je vous entends très bien très bien
vous avez la parole
merci
beaucoup alors par contre j'ai un écho
mais j'espère qu'il ne va pas trop
déranger j'ai un
retour alors ça devra mieux il y avait
un micro qui était resté allumé merciou
oui ça va beaucoup mieux merci beaucoup
euh mesdames messieurs les députés de la
de la commission Défense de l'Assemblée
nationale française euh c'est un un
plaisir d'avoir cet échange avec avec
vous ce matin depuis depuis Dakar au
Sénégal où je suis basé euh et c'est
évidemment aussi un plaisir de de
retrouver d'écouter Arthur banga qui est
un ami et et un collègue
euh alors je pense que j'ai je je vais
quand même dire deux mots sur sur watti
euh bon j'ai été présenté comme
président fondateur c'est vrai que ça
rappelle un peu une chronique euh sur
RFI d'un humoriste nigérien sur la
République du gondouana qui n'est pas
tout à fait démocratique et donc c'est
vrai que le le dème de président
fondateur n'est peut-être pas le plus
approprié euh pour euh porter justement
l'idée de l'idée de de de démocratie
effective euh deux mots sur watti euh
parce que je pense qu'il est important
de situer la perspective à partir de
laquelle je m'exprime euh c'est la
perspective d'un thing tank ouestaricain
qui est basé à Dakar qui est ancré dans
dans la région euh et qui essaie de
mettre au service justement de cette
région euh une plateforme forme de euh
de production et de circulation de
connaissances et d'idées et d'animation
de débat public sur toutes les questions
qui nous sembl être les plus importantes
pour le présent et l'avenir de la région
ouestafricaine sachant que les
frontières de cette région ne sont pas
euh très précisément fixé pour nous
c'est travailler sur l'Afrique de
l'Ouest en donnant aussi le le signal
que nous nous tenons compte de l'extrême
diversité du continent africain que déjà
dans l'espace ouestaricain il y a déjà
beaucoup de diversité et qu'on ne
prétend pas nécessairement avoir une
connaissance suffisante euh de l'Afrique
de l'Est de l'Afrique australe ou de de
la Corne de l'Afrique ou de ou de
l'Afrique du Nord mais la perspective
elle est aussi panafricaine parce qu'il
y a évidemment des leçons à apprendre de
de euh des des uns des autres
euh alors je en 10 minutes je vais
essayer de ne pas reprendre ce qui a été
euh dit très clairement par Arthur banga
sur euh l'état des sociétés civil
africaines et et leur rapport à la
France je vais peut-être parler de
manière un peu plus générale du regard
euh déjà du monde sur l'Afrique en ce
moment et et du regard des Africains sur
eux-mêmes et un peu du regard des des
Africains dans leur diversité sur la
France euh et je vais commencer je ne
suis pas sûr que ce soit le le bon moyen
de de m'attirer de la sympathie par la
citation d'un article de la presse des
États-Unis un article du New York Times
publié euh le 28 octobre donc il y a
vraiment quelques semaines dont les
titrre était the world is becoming more
African euh donc le monde devient de
plus en plus
africain dans cet article on peut lire
notamment en introduction ce ce ce ce ce
texte des changements étonnants sont en
cours en Afrique où la population
devrait presque doubler pour atteindre
2,5 milliards d'habitants au cours du
prochain quart de siècle une are qui non
seulement transformera de nombreux pays
africains selon les experts mais qui
remodèlera aussi radicalement les
relations avec le reste du monde les
taux de natalité chutent dans les pays
riches ce qui suscite des inquiétudes
quant à la manière de prendre soin de
leur société vieillissante et d'en
assurer le financement mais le baby boom
africain se poursuit à un rythme soutenu
alimentant la population la plus jeune
et la plus dynamique de la planète en
195 les Africains représentaient 8 % de
la population mondiale un siècle plus
tard il représent teront un/art de
l'humanité et au moins un tiers de tous
les jeunes âgés de 15 à 24 ans selon les
prévisions des nations- Unies l'âge
médian sur le continent africain est de
19 ans en Inde le pays le plus peuplé du
monde il est de 28 ans en Chine et aux
États-Unis il est de 38 ans fin de
citation on retrouvera d'ailleurs cette
données démographique dans le rapport
d'information sur la relation la France
et l'Afrique de vos collègues de la
Commission des Affaires étrangères
rapport qui a aussi été discuté très
très récemment
euh je cite aussi un autre article il y
a quelques mois en mai dernier toujours
des États-Unis du magazine Foreign
Affairs euh et dont le titre
traduit disait de l'économie mondiale
dépend de l'Afrique un article de
Goldstone et de John may euh et là aussi
un rappelle que l'économie mondiale au
cours des dernières décennies euh sa
croissance a été bâtie de manièreès très
forte sur la croissance de la Chine et
que cette croissance de la Chine était
très liée aussi au poids démographique
de la Chine et au fait qui avait une
main d'œuvre disponible et qui pouvait
donc de manière très forte accélérer la
la productivité en Chine et donc c'est
la croissance chinoise qui a tiré d'une
certaine manière une grande partie de la
croissance mondiale et que ben
maintenant on voit bien s'épuiser
finalement les ressorts en tout cas
démographiques de ces croissant
chinoises et l'article mettait en
évidence le fait que le seul réservoir
de main d'œuvre aujourd'hui pour le
monde c'est l'Afrique euh c'est elle qui
fournira la très grande majorité c'est
près de 90 % de la croissance nette de
la main- d'œuvre dans le monde entre
maintenant et
2040 ce qui me semble être
particulièrement intéressant dans dans
l'article du New York Times auquel je
reviens c'est qu'il ne parle pas
seulement de la démographie et de ce que
cela implique sur le plan économique et
notamment sur la main d'œuvre qui va
être qui va être importante venant du du
continent africain il met aussi en
lumière bien sûr les dynamiques
d'urbanisation mais aussi l'influence
culturelle de de l'Afrique à travers
notamment ses artistes ses musiciens et
je suis sûr
que vous êtes un certain nombre ou en
tout cas peut-être vos vos enfants à
connaître bernaboy Rema avant eux Angeli
Kido pionnaire un peu de de de ces
artistes africains qui euh se produisent
partout dans le monde qui circulent
partout dans le monde et qui aujourd'hui
euh parlent en fait et atteignent la
jeunesse euh en Europe en Amérique et
même jusqu'en jusqu'en Asie et je crois
que cette influence culturelle est aussi
un élément très important euh justement
de cette de cette proposition que le
monde est en train de devenir de plus en
plus
africain et je crois que c'est un tourné
historique euh c'est un tourné
historique d'avoir un monde qui devient
de plus en plus africain lorsqu'on
connaît l'histoire de ce continent euh
notamment les le dernier siècle et demi
qui est quand même essentiellement un
siècle de euh de domination de
marginalisation euh d'exploitation euh
de du du continent africain alors le
continent africain n'est pas le seul à
avoir connu évidemment euh ce ce type de
de de de d'épisode historique euh mais
c'est très clair qu'effectivement euh la
période la plus récente est quand même
celle d'une marginalisation du continent
ce n'est pas celle d'une forte influence
du du continent dans les affaires
mondiales bien au bien au contraire donc
ce qui est en train de se passer qui est
d'abord lié clairement à la démographie
et à la la différence re la démografie
en Afrique et tout ce qui se passe
partout ailleurs dans le monde avec soit
de la décroissance de la population soit
un ralentissement très clair de la
croissance de la population partout
ailleurs euh c'est c'est c'est
historique et euh et ça va avoir
effectivement des impacts importants sur
les rapports de l'Afrique avec le monde
mais aussi sur le regard des Africains
sur eux-mêmes et je pense qu'on en est
déjà là Arthur banga a beaucoup insisté
sur le côté connecté euh de la jeunesse
africaine et je pense que c'est un
élément important euh à force de se
concentrer sur euh les dégâts réel et
important de la désinformation et de la
mésinformation des manipulations
diverses euh parle d'un très grand
nombre d'acteurs euh internationaux euh
on oublie peut-être aussi que l'Internet
et la téléphonie mobilees euh ont
fondamentalement apporté une diversité
de perspectives une diversité de sources
d'information pour les populations
africaines en particulier et que ça ça
aussi induit une forme de de relecture
de l'histoire africaine de l'histoire de
du rapport des pays africains avec les
anciennes puissances euh colon
colonisatrices et que cela aussi
aujourd'hui participe un peu euh du
changement dans la psychologie dans la
perception notamment que les jeunes
africains ont de en deux même de leur
propre pays de leur propre culture de
leurs identités multiples mais aussi de
leurs rapport avec avec la France et
avec tous les autres tous les autres
acteurs internationaux
h je crois que cela ne veut pas dire que
les les défis ne sont pas monstrueux
hein les défis lié à la démographie
notamment du continent sur le plan euh
sanitaire éducatif économique sont
absolument colossaux et donc le fait
d'avoir une population en croissance
d'être le le réservoir de main d'œuvre
du monde ne signifie pas que les les
conditions de vie en Afrique vont
nécessairement s'améliorer de manière
significative tout dépendra bien sûr des
choix politiques qui seront fait et de
la capacité qu'on aura à redresser ce
qu'on n pas fait en terme de politique
publique pendant des décennies et à
changé aussi le rapport au reste du
monde euh ce qui me semblait important
peut-être de souligner par rapport à la
France en particulier euh c'est que euh
on peut voir aujourd'hui en Afrique de
l'Ouest et au Sahel
euh un rejet alors pas un rejet de la
France ce terme de sentiment
anti-rançais euh très présent dans les
médias je pense qu'il est il ne décrit
pas la réalité parce que je n'ai pas
connaissance d'actes ciblés sur des
individus français dans qu'une capitale
ouest-africaine euh même dans les pays
saéliens où les relations diplomatiques
sont les plus difficiles il y a un rejet
une contestation de l'influence
politique militaire et économique
française telle qu'elle est perçue là
aussi que cette perception soit exagérée
et s tout à fait établie dans certains
cas mais c'est une perception qui est
aussi bâtie parfois sur des sur des
faits et qui est bâtie surtout sur une
histoire réelle effectivement de
colonisation et de décolonisation et de
prolongement de cette influence euh par
euh par les des mécanismes que que tout
le monde connaît aujourd'hui et qui ne
sont pas spécifiques d'ailleurs hein à
la France on a euh toutes les puissance
grande et moyen dans le monde essaient
de défendre leurs intérêts et le font
euh voilà avec les moyens et la
supériorité dont il dispose mais je
crois qu'on a aussi aujourd'hui
euh au-delà de de la situation dans le
Sahel hein sur laquelle on pourra
revenir on a ailleurs où il y a pas
cette présence militaire française il y
a pas eu des interventions euh
militaires il y a aussi euh simplement
la réalisation disons de la nécessité de
passer à autre chose de tourner vraiment
la page un peu de la de la de la
décolonisation et des mécanismes qui ont
été mis en place après cette c'est les
indépendances formelles pour arriver à
ce que les Ivoiriens appelai pendant la
crise une deuxième indépendance pendant
longtemps je trouvais ce terme pas
approprié mais au fond lorsque je le
réexamine aujourd'hui oui il y a un
véritable sentiment de désir de deuxème
indépendance euh qui traduit voilà
l'état d'esprit d'une nouvelle d'une
nouvelle génération euh qui euh même si
elle n'a pas connu la colonisation et
les et ce qu'on appelle communément la
francearique euh évidemment elle lit
elle s'informe peut-être pas toujours
très bien mais elle a une une
connaissance de ce passé et
effectivement cela euh la pousse à
demander une forme de de rupture je
crois que euh j'ai déjà fait mes mes 10
minutes alors je vais essayer de
conclure j'avais beaucoup d'autres
éléments mais je pense que la les
échanges les les questions permettront
d'aller d'aller d'aller plus loin euh
mais je je deux choses pour terminer la
première c'est que je crois que du côté
français il y a en particulier de besoin
de de réaliser que à nouveau l'histoire
coloniale et et encore plus l'histoire
de l'influence française après les
indépendances elle est extrêmement
récente lorsqu'on considère la longue
durée des états on parle de quelque
chose d'extrêmement récent euh et donc
on peut pas s'attendre à ce que cela ne
compte pas et les effets politique
économique symbolique de cette influence
française sont encore présents et donc
je crois que il est vraiment important
de réaliser qu'il faut passer à autre
chose euh et qu'il faut pas nier la
nécessité le besoin pour euh les les
jeunesses africaines euh bah de dire
nous connaissons cette histoire et euh
nous souhaitons maintenant avoir de
nouvelles relations qui soient
simplement au fond les mêmes qu'avec les
autres partenaires euh dans le monde et
le deuxième élément et je crois que ça
aussi ça a été souligné dans le rapport
d'information euh de vos collègues
députés de la commission des affaires
étrangères lorsqu'on regarde la
perception de la France dans la région
on voit bien que euh elle est euh très
différente euh en Afrique de l'Ouest
lorsqu'on compare à l'Afrique australe
et et et et à l'Afrique de l'Est et on
voit bien qu'évidemment c'est là où la
France a été politiquement militairement
économiquement très présence dans ses
anciennes colonies que cette perception
est la plus négative euh c'est tout tout
à fait là aussi normal et je pense que
c'est ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui c'est une
forme de transition c'est une transition
qui de mon point de vue est est naturel
et sincrit dans la dans la dans la dans
la longue durée et et enfin regardez
simplement les chiffres à nouveau
démographique la France et l'Allemagne
lorsque vous combinez les populations de
la France et de l'Allemagne en 2023
peut-être encore davantage lorsque vous
regardez les prévisions pour 2050 et
vous les comparez à la population du
seul Nigéria vous comprenez
qu'effectivement les poids
démographiques ont changé et que c'est
tout à fait naturel qui a aussi une
demande de changement dans la forme et
dans le fond de ces relations je vais
m'arrêter là et je m'excuse d'avoir été
un peu plus long que les le temps qui
m'était imparti merci beaucoup bien et
ben écoutez merci cher gilabi pour
ce ce ce propos et merci d'ailleurs de
nous montrer également qu'à Dakar il y a
de la bonne connectivité réseau puisque
précédemment on avait le professeur memb
mais c'était plus un problème local
qu'il avait sur son ordinateur qui
faisait que la vio n'était pas de très
bonne qualité alors que là vous nous
avez montré que les conditions
techniques étaient parfaitement réunies
alors pour terminer ces ces
introductions je vais désormais donner
la parole à Gill Yabi est-ce que vous
nous entendez euh pardon à autant pour
moi à à Karim bitard autant pour moi
Karim Bitar est-ce que vous nous
entendez bonjour monsieur le Président
oui je vous entends très bien je suis à
Beyou côté un pays où parfois des
problèmes de technologie peuvent
également survenir compte tenu de la
décpitude des infrastructures et bien
pour l'instant la visionférence est de
bonne qualité écoutez nous nous vous
avez la parole
euh donc merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés donc
je m'adresse à vous depuis beyouth et je
faisais allusion au fait que ce pays
traverse une véritable crise
existentielle aujourd'hui encore plus
fragilisé par la guerre en cours depuis
les massacres du 7 octobre le pogrom qui
a coûté la vie à plus de 1200 civils
israéliens et la réaction euh des
mesures mesuré de l'armée israélienne
qui a déjà provoqué plus de 12000 morts
donc ce que cette question vient
rappeler à tous c'est la persistance de
la question palestinienne euh sa
centralité et son universalité et cela
me permet d'aborder les question de
l'Afrique du Nord et du Maghreb parce
que euh c'est l'une des régions où l'on
sent euh un sentiment de solidarité
envers ce qui se passe à Gaza qui est
particulièrement marqué on est en train
de réaliser jour après jours jusqu'à
quel point le monde dans lequel on vit
est marqué par une stupéfiante
interdépendance qu'il y a une charge
émotionnelle extrêmement lourde et que
ce qui se passe sous nos yeux est un
conflit global qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas possible de restreindre à une seule
zone ce n'est pas un conflit de basse
intensité ce n'est pas un conflit mineur
ça se répercute à
Tunis à
Alger à Rabat et ailleurs euh donc pour
évoquer les sociétés de l'Afrique du
Nord et du Maghreb aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il est indispensable de revenir 12
ans en arrière en 2011 ce à quoi nous
avons assisté était une véritable
rupture épistémologique avec la révolte
de vaste frange de la jeunesse
tunisienne qui a permis la chute de
Monsieur Benali le 14 janvier 2011 nous
avons vu pour la première prère fois des
êtres humains de chair et de sang dans
cette partie du monde qui avaient enfin
la capacité de se faire entendre par les
opinions publiques occidentales car
l'Occident a longtemps perçu cette
partie du monde l'Afrique et le monde
arabo-musulman en particulier à travers
certains prismes déformants des prismes
ethnocentriques des prismes orientaliste
et on voyait uniquement ce fameux
triptique d'un côté l'idée qu'il y a un
despote oriental qui est au pouvoir et
Kaddafi était la parfaite illustration
de ce despote oriental quelque chose
qu'on appelait l'islam sans tenir compte
de l'extraordinaire spécificité euh de
l'extraordinaire diversité à l'intérieur
de cette ère civilisationnelle qui
regroupe des dizaines de pays des
dizaines de langues des dizaines de
mouvances religieuses et idéologiques et
on voyait derrière le despote oriental
derrière euh
ce qu'on appelle l'islam dans en
utilisant une expression englobante qui
ne veut plus dire grand-chose il y avait
aussi la question des ressources
énergétiques bien évidemment donc
derrière ce triptique despot oriental
Islam ressource on ne voulait pas voir
où on occultait les êtres humains de
cher et de sang les populations les
sociétés civiles qui se sont révoltés
massivement c'était essentiellement des
révolutions de la dignité ont réclamé le
pain et la liberté mais surtout la
dignité euh l'expérience tunisienne a
montré qu'on a pu avoir pendant une
période d'une décennie une transition
démocratique qui malgré son incapacité à
résoudre tous les problèmes sociaux et
économiques ont quand même a quand même
montré qu'il était possible de conjuguer
un espace de liberté et une alternance
au pouvoir puisqu'il y a euant plusieurs
alternances malheureusement nous sommes
revenu aujourd'hui à la case départ dans
la
quasittalité des pays de la région la
contre révolution l'a emporté un peu
partout et plus spécifiquement en
Tunisie depuis que le Président actuel
Kais said enseignant en droit
constitutionnel a suspendu la
Constitution commencer à emprisonner et
à persécuter tous ses opposants les
dissidents il incarne un phénomène de
plus en plus répandu aujourd'hui à
l'échelle mondiale un retour d'un
national populisme d'un autoritarisme
matiné d'une forte dose de
conspirationnisme également vous avez
peut-être vu récemment sa déclaration
assez hallucinante où il évoquait
l'ouragan Daniel en disant que c'était
un complot parce que Daniel était le nom
d'un prophète hébraïque donc vous voyez
ce mélange de nationalisme
d'antisémitisme de complotisme de
populisme qui est de retour au pouvoir
en Tunisie alors même que l'on espérait
que ce pays allait donner un modèle
pour une évolution démocratique libérale
et progressiste pour tous les pays euh
d'Afrique du Nord et également
euh dans le reste du monde arabe donc
retour à la ce départ en Tunisie et je
me dois de pointer devant vous une
certaine
responsabilité française européenne
occidentale en général dans le retour de
cet autoritarisme on a le sentiment
parfois vu du Sud global qu'il peut y
avoir une préférence occidentale pour
l'autoritarisme c'est-à-dire qu'on voit
les dirigeants de la région
essentiellement comme des gardes
frontières comme ceux qui vont empêcher
des vagues migratoires de déferler sur
l'Europe et on a tendance à fermer les
yeux sur leur dériv autoritaire
liberticide et on gagne ainsi une
stabilité à très court terme en plantant
les germes d'une instabilité de plus
long terme qui risque d'affecter non
seulement l'Afrique du Nord mais
également d'affecter l'Europe donc ce
qui pass en Tunisie est particulièrement
préoccupant on ironise là-bas en disant
qu'à l'époque de Benali on avait un peu
de développement économique on avait le
pain mais on avait pas la possibilité de
s'exprimer librement donc aucune liberté
pendant la période de la transition
démocratique qui a eu une certaines
liberté d'expression mais la crise
économique s'est aggravée donc pas de
pain et aujourd'hui il y a plus ni pain
ni liberté on est véritablement revenu à
une période qui est infiniment plus
inquiétante que celle que euh n'ont pu
connaître les régimes les plus
autoritaires du monde arabe pendant ces
quatre dernières décennies euh en
Algérie euh la situation est également
préoccupante on a le sentiment notamment
quand on étudie les relations
franco-algériennes que la cicatrisation
mémoriale n'a pas encore pu se faire que
le passé reste extrêmement présent euh
60 ans après l'indépendance de l'Algérie
a encore beaucoup de récrimination le
passé n'est jamais mort il n'est jamais
passé disait l'écrivain américain
William fulkner et cela est
particulièrement vrai dans les relations
entre l'Algérie et la France on a le
sentiment que des événements qui se sont
produit il y a plusieurs décennies reste
aujourd'hui capable de susciter des
émotions à fleur de peau on voit parfois
le président tboun utilisé d'une
certaine rhtorique pour mobiliser son
opinion publique contre la France on a
également le sentiment que le Hirak le
mouvement de protestation des démocrates
et des libéraux algériens euh n'a pas eu
le soutien qu'il aurait pu mériter de la
part de l'Europe et du reste du monde
euh donc il y a une sorte de
consolidation autoritaire qui est
toujours en cours dans la région le
Maroc nous offre une situation un peu
plus singulière le Maroc est confronté
certes à des problèmes sociaux et
économiques véritablement considérables
il y a également certaines atteintes aux
libertés publiques notamment au droits
des journalistes qui doivent être
signalés mais le a
réussi quelque peu mieux à juguler cette
colère populaire née en 2011 en
réformant sa constitution et à offrir un
certain modèle de respect du pluralisme
le Maroc est l'un des pays de la région
où il y a une communauté juive
particulièrement présente qui a été
protégée pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale alors que certains pays
européens persécutter les Juifs
aujourd'hui le Maroc est l'un des pays
qui sera affecté par ce qui se passe en
Israël et à Gaza euh parce que c'est un
pays qui avait
euh joué le jeu des accords d'Abraham
s'était rapproché d'Israël et on a vu
que les opinions publiques n'étaient pas
sur la même longueur d'ondte que les
dirigeants et ça c'est un point commun
de toutes les sociétés de la région une
rupture entre les opinions publiques et
les dirigeants qui ne sont plus
représentatifs donc on en a eu euh un
exemple au moment de la coupe du monde
de football au Qatar lorsque l'équipe
marocaine a commencé à gagner plusieurs
matchs euh les joueurs sans référer à
leurs autorités politiques ont brandi le
drapeau palestinien et sont devenus un
peu des symboles de l'Atlantique
jusqu'au golf de cette persistance de la
question palestiniennes les opinions
publiques restent très sensibles aux
injustices subies par les Palestiniens
et c'est sans doute ces images-là qui
ont conduit le prince héritier saoudien
l'émire du Qatar les émiratis à réalisé
que les opinion publique n'était pas
encore prête à une normalisation à un
processus de paix avec Israël tant que
les droits des Palestiniens n'auront pas
été respecté c'est sans doute cela qui a
conduit à mettre un peu à ralentir ce
processus notamment dans le cas de
l'Arabie Saoudite donc les autorités
marocaines doivent aujourd'hui
s'efforcer de maintenir un jeu
d'équilibriste de tenir compte de la
colère de leur population colère
légitime contre tenue du carnage qui se
déroule à Gaza mais aussi de maintenir
ce respect du pluralisme qui a
historiquement marqué le Maroc et cette
capacité d'être un intermédiaire le cas
de la Libye illustre également une
certaine faillite de l'interventionnisme
débridé on a réussi à faire tomber
l'atroce dictature de Monsieur Kaddafi
qui était resté 41 ans au pouvoir de
1969 à 2011 mais le fait que la chute de
Kaddafi est été la conséquence d'une
intervention militaire des pays de
l'OTAN et euh que d'innombrables milices
locales a pu émerger font que la Libye
se retrouve aujourd'hui 12 ans après
dans
l'incapacité d'avoir un état qui a le
monopole sur la violence légitime euh et
euh de contrôler les milices et les
armes qui prolifèrent ce qui rend la
situation encore plus compliquée c'est
que la situation en Libye est devenu à
bien des égards une guerre par
procuration entre des puissances
régionales nous nous en avons l'habitude
au levant le Liban a beaucoup connu des
guerres par procuration sur son
territoire mais aujourd'hui ce sont euh
certains États en Afrique du Nord
notamment la Libye où se jouent ces
rivalités entre le Qatar les Émirats
arabes unis beaucoup d'autres puissances
la Russie est également présente et se
sert parfois de des maladresses
occidentales et de certaines hypocrisie
occidental pour essayer de prendre pied
aussi bien en Afrique du Nord qu'en
Afrique subsaharienne
donc il me semble aujourd'hui plus que
jamais indispensable que l'Europe et la
France en particulier restent fidèles à
ses valeurs euh de libéralisme de
démocratie de respect du pluralisme de
respect des droits de l'homme et qu'on
ne revienne pas au schéma d'avant 2011
qui nous faisait croire qu'en soutenant
certains régimes autoritaires nous
allions gagner en stabilité nous allions
gagner euh en évitant que des vagues
migratoires ne nous
euh ne touchent les frontières
européennes mais nous ne faisons que
retarder le problème nous ne faisons que
gagner un répi temporaire et nous
suscitons une colère de plus en plus
vive il est absolument indispensable que
l'Afrique du Nord puisse aujourd'hui
trouver les voies d'un nouveau
développement économique d'un nouveau
contrat social et puisse conjuguer
libéralisme politique et justice sociale
et développement économique je voudrais
vraiment m'inscrire en faux contre cette
idée qui revient en force dans le débat
public selon lequel qu il y a un
exceptionnalisme arabe que les pays de
la région de l'Afrique du Nord ou du
Moyen-Orient ont besoin d'avoir à leur
tête des hommes forts des dictateurs qui
maintiennent l'ordre qui évitent la
montée des mouvements terroristes qui
empêchent
l'migration je pense que c'est là une
logique profondément erronée les masses
qu'on a vu manifester en 2011 étaient là
pour montrer qu'il y avait une troisième
voix dans cette partie du monde entre
les régimes autoritaires nationalistes
militaristes et les mouvements
islamistes radicaux il y a aussi
énormément de libéraux de démocrates de
progressistes dans le monde arabe qui
souhaitent se faire entendre en Afrique
du Nord et dans le reste des pays de la
région mais ils sont ils ont souvent le
sentiment de ne pas trouver d'oreille
attentiv de l'autre côté de la
Méditerranée ils ont le sentiment que
les Européens les ont quelque peu
abandonné à leur sort et sont revenus à
ce vieux réflexe qui consiste à soutenir
les régimes autoritaires donc derrière
cette façade de consolidation
autoritaire il il y a toujours une
colère qui bouille il y a toujours des
sociétés qui bouillonnent des sociétés
extrêmement vivaces avec une scène
culturelle artistique très présente une
volonté d'émancipation mais ces libéraux
et ces démocrates euh berbères ou arabes
en Afrique du Nord euh chrétiens et
musulmans au Liban et ailleurs tous nous
sommes tous devenus minoritaires d'une
certaine façon dans un monde marqué par
une interdépendance et cette euh
hybridité que Curel ne pourra être géré
que dans le cadre d'une émergence de la
citoyenneté d'une égalité des droits et
des devoirs entre tous les citoyens mais
aussi il faut espérer que le
gouvernement français les autres
gouvernements européens feront preuve de
beaucoup plus de sévérité envers
certains dirigeants qui ont repris les
vieilles habitudes de l'autoritarisme de
la répression car cela créer les
conditions qui vont permettre
l'émergence peut-être dans 10 ans
peut-être dans 20 ans d'une nouvelle
vague d'une nouvelle génération de
mouvements terroristes et de vagues
d'émigration encore plus importantes que
celle qu'onnaissit aujourd'hui
péniblement de jugulé donc au-delà de ce
qui se passe dans la région il y a
également une responsabilité française
européenne et occidentale et ce n'est
que par un partenariat
entre l'Occident et les sociétés civiles
monde arabe qu'on pourra évoluer vers
une démocratisation et qui pourrait être
pérenne et non pas uniquement temporaire
comme ce fut le cas dans la Tun dans
l'exemple tunisien je vous remercie
mesdames et messieurs et je suis disposé
à répondre à toutes vos questions merci
pour ce panorama très complet de la
situation dans les pays du Maghreb et se
pldoyer d'une certaine manière pour le
développement démocratique et économique
qui seul pe apporter des solutions de de
long terme nous allons prendre les
différentes interventions des orateurs
de groupe en commençant par le groupe
rassemblement national la parole est à
José
Gonzales
merci merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les chercheurs merci pour vos
interventions engissantes nous sommes
ravi de vous accueillir ce matin en
audition votre expertise et votre
éclairage sur des sujets aussi vastes et
complexes que la question des sociétés
africaine permettra coup sûr d'affiner
nos travaux parlementaires le continent
africain continent de la démograie
continent de la démographie dépassera
les 4,5 milliards d'habitants en 2100 et
devra donc répondre à de multiples défis
un défi économique car il est confronté
à de multiples chocs tels que les effets
de la pandémie de covid-19 les
perturbations des chaînes
d'approvisionnement exacerbé par
l'invasion de l'Ukraine et le
resserrement des conditions financières
mondiales ces chocs qui ont entraîné une
réduction du taux de croissance réelle
de 4,8 % 2021 à 3,8 % 2022 mais ont
également permis de démontrer la
résilience des économies africaines
un défi sécuritaire et démocratique nous
assistons en effet à une aggravation de
l'instabilité des sous-régions fragiles
comme le Sahel miné par les mouvements
djihadistes tant au sein des pays
anglophones tels que le Nigéria le
Cameroun que dans des régions
francophones du Sahel où la France a
d'ailleurs acté la fin de l'opération
barcane nous assistons également à un
regain des tensions entre États
notamment au sein de la Corne de
l'Afrique où la fragile Somalie cohabite
avec un Soudan instable confronté à un
gain de violence et une Éthiopie secouée
par le conflit du Tigré à cela s'ajoute
enfin le défi climatique car l'Afrique
subit les conséquences du réchauffement
climatique Haus de température
sècheresse érosion des côtes risque
d'affassement des sols et inondations
les défis sont immenses et les moyens
limités les perspectives économiques
soulignent en ce sens l'urgence
d'accélérer l'action climatique et les
transition verte pour stimuler le
développement inclusif et durable du
continent afin de répondre au besoin
besoin de financement climatique du
continent estimé à 2,8 à pardon à
2800 milliards de dollars sur la période
2020-2030 ces défis auront des
conséquences importantes sur les
populations concernées et un impact
direct sur la crise migratoire
aujourd'hui d'ors et déjà si aigu en
Méditerranée nous sommes intéressés par
votre regard sur ces questions sur les
perspectives pour les pays africains
concernés les solutions politiques adopt
la résilience démocratique de ces états
et sur le rôle que pourront jouer la
France l'Occident et le monde pour
soutenir les pays africains et enrayer
la crise migratoire aujourd'hui synonyme
de tragédie et de marchandisation de
l'humain quel regard également sur
l'aide au développement et ses effets
sur ce continent cuid de l'aide au
développement bilatéral je vous remercie
merci alors je vous propose de prendre
les question par groupe de 3 pour avoir
une réponse consolidée pour le groupe la
France insoumise la parole est à
François pckman oui merci monsieur le
président ainsi qu'à aux trois
intervenants alors il est vrai que la
France fait face à une forte
contestation de sa présence en Afrique
sur beaucoup de plans pour autant il est
important de rappeler que ce n'est pas
la France en elle-même qui est contesté
mais peut-être davantage une certaine
idée de la France après des années de
politique néocoloniale et de la
France-Afrique qu'on a connu ces
dernières décennies aussi aije deux
questions en parti parulier dans quelle
mesure est-ce que selon vous les
positions tenues par la France sur les
différents coups d'État et leur
dénonciation à géométries variable par
nos élites politiques ont influencé les
ressentis des populations aussi bien
envers leurs propres élites politiques
que les gouvernant et que la France
seconde question sur la question du
dénigrement de l'image de la France on
entend souvent que les populations sur
place sont influencé par des puissances
extérieures notamment la Chine et la
Russie alors nous pensons que si des
puissances ont pu utiliser effectivement
ce ressenti s'en servir à l'encontre de
l'image de la France et potentiellement
de ses intérêts celle-ci porte une
grande responsabilité dans ce déficit
d'image Hut égard aux déclarations de
certains de ces dirigeants à des prises
de position officielles il est donc
intéressant de voir dans quelle mesure
les personnes auditionnées en
l'occurrence vous sont en accord ou non
avec cette position et enfin troisième
question puisque nous avions àchil
bembeé précédemment il parlait des
différentes postures que pouvait avoir
la France et il a eu cette notion assez
intéressante de juste distance euh
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous vous en
pensez quels seraient les chemins à
trouver pour que la France retrouve un
langage commun avec les pays les pays
africains et peut-être sur la question
écologique et et de la défense du vivant
je vous remercie merci pour le groupe
les républicains la parole est à
Jean-Louis tiierot merci monsieur le
Président merci messieurs de de vos
apports très très
enrichissants la première question que
je souhaiterais vous poser concerne le
champ des perceptions je souhaiterais
selon vous est-ce que les difficulté de
perception que nous connaissons pour la
France concerne spécifiquement la France
ou que par exemple d'ancienne puissance
coloniale type les Britanniques
subissent le la même problèm de
perception est-ce que les histoires
coloniales différentes ont aussi des des
conséquences différentes dans les
perceptions deuxème question toujours
dans la perception est-ce que c'est la
France qui est spécifiquement visé ou
c'est perçu comme l'Occident en général
West versus the rest comme on l'entend
et enfin dernier point toujours dans les
perceptions est-ce que Les Afriques et
j'emploie volontairement le terme Les
Afriques parce que je crois qu'on ne
peut pas en faire un seul ensemble ont
le sentiment d'appartenir au sud global
est-ce que le sud global pour eux veut
dire pour elle pour Les Afriques veut
dire quelque chose enfin dernière
question qui se porte plutôt sur
l'intervention de Monsieur bitard je
crois qu'ici nous souhaitons tous que le
vœux d'une libéralisation générale
notamment de l'Afrique du Nord se met en
place mais est-ce que vous ne croyez pas
que c'est quand même dans le monde
général avec le populisme qui se
développe partout une forme de vœux
pieux et notamment une inquiétude en
Algérie nous avons tous entendu le
président de la République française
quand il avait parler de rente
mémorielle on sait à quel point la
mémoire des événements de la
décolonisation sont aujourd'hui un outil
de justification du maintien au pouvoir
du FLN donc quels sont les espoirs et
quelle est la réalité d'une opposition
démocratique en Algérie merci à vous
alors merci au collègues pour cette
première série de de questions je vous
propose d'y répondre en prenant environ
5 minutes chacun dans le même ordre que
l'ordre initial et pour la prochaine
série on pourra inverser l'ordre si vous
le souhaitez et et essayer dans vos
réponses si possible de d'essayer de
complément d'être complémentaire pour
pas aborder plusieurs fois le le même
sujet Arthur BR vous avez la
parole bien je vais je vais commencer
j'ai le choix je vais commencer par par
l'idée de de globalement ce que
j'appelle la cohérence dans la politique
étrangère il y a trop de cohérence
d'incohérence dans la politique
étrangère et ça s'est vu sur le coups
d'État euh on a eu par exemple un Zè
très fort sur le sur le Mali sur le
Niger par exemple on a eu une sorte de
de de kitus donné au Tchad on a une
sorte d'hésitation même limite
d'acceptation au Gabon ça donne pas une
clarté de la position je pense que la PR
première chose c'est d'avoir une
clarteté de la position voilà elle est
claire après euh avoir un principe
est-ce qu'on condamne un coups d'État si
oui on les condamne est-ce que on les
condamne jusqu'à quel niveau il faut il
faut tenir ça après peut-être dans le
temps avec des négociation avec
l'évolution de la situation bougé mais
quand on a l'impression que au Niger ou
au Mali les gens ont commis un crime à
travers un coup d'état alors qu' au
Tchad c'est pas le cas au Gabon c'est
accepté c'est incohérent et cette
incohérence est un est un vrai problème
pour la politique étrangère française on
comprend qu'il peut y avoir des intérêts
on comprend qu'il peut y avoir des
choses mais il faut un minimum de
cohérence parce que quand il y a pas ce
minimum de cohérence ça devient
inaudible tout ce que vous allez prendre
comme initiative et encore plus quand
vous allez parler de démocratie on va
vous rappeler he ces incohérences en
politique étrangère il faut de la
cohérence dans cette dans cette
politique
étrangère je vais revenir aussi
rapidement sur la notion de de
perception euh euh perception entre la
France et les autres en fait faut
comprendre que la France est le est le
seul pays qui a une véritable politique
africaine au lendemain de de de de la
des indépendances pour les Anglais un
peu moins pour les autres mais de Gaul
dans sa conception de puissant
d'ailleurs l'ouvrage de Maurice Weiss la
grandeur dans la politique étrangère du
général de GA est assez intéressant on
voit que sa politique étrangère ça est
une politique de grandeur de puissance
sur deux pieds le pied européen avec la
construction franco-allemande et toute
l'Union européenne mais a le pays
africain qui s'appuie sur ses colonies
et donc c'est la France qui a qui est le
pays qui a plus une une sorte de de
politique de cette volonté de maintenir
des liien à travers le les liens
militaires les bases militaires les
liens économiques et tout ça qui peut se
comprendre en certains moments mais la
conséquence c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est
le pays qui est plus en pointe même si
on l' vu dans la dernière visite de de
Charles I au Kenya dans certains pays
pays on peut encore revendiquer des
choses en Namibie ils ont revendiqué euh
euh reconnaissance plus dédommagement
mais la France a une vraie politique
africaine et donc il y a une conséquence
aujourd'hui ce qui fait que la
perception est beaucoup plus forte quand
il s'agit de France et finalement pour
répondre au à France ou Occident ça
devient de plus en plus Occident euh
c'est lié à l'environnement mondial
parce que la guerre en Ukraine les
positions sur la crise palestinienne euh
même des positions face à certains coups
d'État
donne l'impression qu'il y a il y a une
voix occidentale et donc la contestation
française devient de plus en plus une
contestation occidentale euh euh dans
dans dans l'analyse dans et dans la
perception des choses euh
oui la question de de la juste distance
euh oui oui il faut il faut euh avoir
cette juste distance mais le problème
c'est juste à quel moment on on a une
juste distance est-ce que on ferme les
yeux cont au Niger par exemple un
président élu
démocratiquement qui engage des réformes
et qui bénéficie de l'assistance
française est renversé par un PCH le
plus incompréhensible est-ce qu'on se
tait au nom de la juste distance voilà
il faut trouver la place en cohérence et
juste distance mais il y a les sujets de
toute façon sur lesquels on peut vous on
peut pas être distant sur les sujets
d'écologie sur les sujets de démocratie
sur les sujet de pauvreté parce que
cette distance on la paye le le le
collègue libana par d'interdépendance
voilà après je pense que le meilleur
mécanisme dans dans cette histoire de
juste distance pour moi c'est de de
faire confiance aux organisations
régionales africaines d'essayer de de
s'allier aux décisions qu'elles
prendront d'essayer de leur donner plus
de moyens et surtout sur le plan
militaire cette juste distance passe
pour moi par la non intervention moi je
suis très clair euh les interventions
militaire alimente euh derrière tout
parce qu'il y a une tradition
d'intervention militaire qui a été
pendant longtemps des interventions
politiques et aujourd'hui cette
intervention n'a plus sa place d'un
point de vue militaire donc juste
distance sur le plan militaire oui en se
concentrant par exemple sur la montée en
puissance sur des sur sur de la
formation he sur de l'équipement juste
distance aussi sur la monnaie hein parce
que je pense qu'il est le temps il est
temps aujourd'hui de tourner la page du
franc CFA le discours de 2019 à Abidjan
était assez intéressant en terme de
réforme mais depuis 2019 on a un statut
qu voilà il faut trouver des mécanismes
pour être moins Mo présent et je pense
qu'en étant moins présent on va je
dirais pas banaliser normaliser la
relation afro-française et tirer de
cette relation tout ce qu'il y a de de
positif d'autant plus qu'il y a des
atouts qui sont uniques dans dans cette
dans cette relationre Afrique et
notamment c'est c'est c'est ces colonies
ces anciennes colonies notamment les
diasporas la langue la culture les les
échanges universitaires les jeunesses
voici voici des éléments assez
importants sur lesquels on peut
construire le soutien à la démocratie
par exemple et et mon collègue de de de
de de du Maghreb en a parlé la France
aujourd'hui autant en 90 le discours de
la B a donné un un coup d'accélérateur
aux démocratie aux partisans de la
démocratie aujourd'hui il n'y a pas ce
coup d'accélérateur et les partisans de
la démocratie les partisans de la
liberté manquent souvent de cette de
cette de ce soutien français bon euh je
pense que j'ai mis une minute en plus et
je vais je vais m'arrêter là en
permettant à mes collègues de de
compléter mes réponse merci la parole
est à gilieabit toujours pour continuer
à tenter de répondre aux questions qui
ont été posées
oui merci merci beaucoup et et merci
pour pour toutes ces questions qui sont
toutes très intéressante et très
difficile euh je vais peut-être
commencer par la les différences
peut-être de de perception
euh la la France et et d'autres euh
anciens pays européens
colonisateur comme comme le le le les
Britanniques et je pense que peut-être
la la la notion de distance est
peut-être la la bonne manière de
répondre à cela euh euh et je crois
qu'il y a eu beaucoup plus de distance
euh de la part de euh voilà du
Royaume-Uni par exemple lorsqu'on
compare avec la France quant aux
relations qui se sont établies après euh
les indépendances je pense que c'est
c'est c'est très clair et et je pense
qu'il y a un élément peut-être qui euh
qui ne revient pas souvent qu'on
nexplore pas comme étant l'une des
explications de cette absence de
distance de cette proximité politique
qui s'est établie entre la France et des
et beaucoup de pays d'Afrique de l'Ouest
et du Centre anciennees colonies c'est
le système politique lui-même c'est
qu'on a en France un système politique
qui lui-même est est quand même très
incarné par par la le le président de la
République et et au fond ce qu'on
reproche beaucoup ce que beaucoup
d'Africains en réalité reprochent à la
France c'est le fait d'avoir des
relations politiques au plus haut niveau
directement entre chefs d'État et au
fond de se servir de ces relations
politiques privilégiés pour avoir des
avantages économiques notamment pour la
pour la France et donc ça euh on voit
bien que ça a un lien avec le système
politique lui-même et je crois que dans
les systèmes qui sont notamment
parlementaires euh ou simplement avec un
peu plus de un peu plus de de de de
contrepouvoir ou en tout cas
d'implication de différents pôles dans
le débat public et dans lesc ion de
politique extérieure on a quand même je
crois un un élément très important de
d'explication de cette de cette
différence un peu un peu française et ça
renvoie à la nécessité peut-être aussi
de réfléchir je pense en tout cas du
côté des pays euh euh francophones à des
réformes institutionnelles profondes
pour justement réduire significativement
la la personnalisation du pouvoir et la
la présidentialisation
euh une remarque je pense sur ce le le
le le premier le premier commentaire qui
a été fait sur les les défis colossaux
du du continent je pense que je l'ai
mentionné hein dans la dans la dans dans
le propos liminaire les défis sont sont
immenses éducatif sanitaires économique
lorsqu'on prend en compte aussi le
changement climatique et la croissance
démographique euh mais mais je crois
que je pense que le le le député qui
s'est exprimé a commencer par mentionner
covid euh le resserrement des conditions
financières internationales la crise en
Ukraine bon ce sont des éléments
importants ce sont des éléments qui ont
affecté le continent africain mais je
pense très honnêtement que ce sont des
éléments très conjoncturels et que ce
qui fait la différence au niveau de
l'amélioration des conditions de vie des
populations c'est pas la croissance sur
un an ou sur 2 ans c'est la croissance
sur deux décennies ou trois décennies
c'est la transformation économique et
sociale et ça ça ne demande pas
simplement d'avoir à nouveau de bon taux
de croissance sur quelques années donc
la vraie question c'est qu'est-ce
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n' pas eu une
transformation économique euh comparable
à ce qu'on a pu voir dans d'autres
parties du monde en Asie évidemment mais
pas seulement et qui aurait permis
d'avoir aujourd'hui des conditions de
vie d'accès à l'énergie qui soit qui
soit pas aussi aussi mauvaise lorsqu'on
regarde les indicateurs aujourd'hui
d'accès à l'électricité dans beaucoup de
pays du continent il y a une grande
diversité mais quand même on a des pays
où les les taux sont extrêmement bas et
avec ça on peut pas avoir du véritable
développement économique et et et social
donc je pense qu'il faut on peut pas
mettre en avant des facteurs qui sont
récents et qui sont conurelle pour
expliquer des dynamiques de longue durée
la question stratégique sur le plan
économique de mon point de vue c'est
c'est la question des ressources
naturelles de leur transformation locale
et il faut qu'on mette dans la
discussion et compris dans les relations
avec les partenaires extérieurs les
vraies questions économiques bah ce qui
va changer c'est la possibilité d'avoir
localement de la transformation de
l'industrialisation de la création de
valeur et ça induit effectivement aussi
une remise en cause d'un certain nombre
de de conditions dans la dans la dans la
le commerce des des des ressources des
ressources naturelles euh un un dernier
point euh parce que je pense qu'à
nouveau comme il faut être très très
bref euh sur la question de de la Chine
de la Russie des manipulations de la
désinformation je crois que c'est un
fait il y a des c'est factuel on peut on
peut on peut montrer qu'il y a des
entreprises de de manipulation les les
les grands réseaux sociaux de temps en
temps supprime des dizaines voir des
centaines de comptes euh et qui montrent
effectivement et bien qu'il y a de la de
la manipulation la désinformation euh
par la Russie mais pas seulement je
crois que c'est important aussi de
mentionner par exemple qu'il y a quand
même eu beaucoup de de journalistes qui
ont fait du travail qui ont montré que
derrière ces manipulations on a parfois
eu des entreprises de sécurité
israélienne notamment qui offr aussi des
des services de de de de d'organisation
de la de la manipulation de
l'information euh donc c'est une réalité
mais je crois qu'évidemment le on peut
pas expliquer le le rejet de la
politique française
essentiellement par par ces ces ces
manipulations par par les réseaux russes
et et d'autres euh je crois que c'est ce
sera une lecture très très réductrice
c'est de l'opportunisme en particulier
lorsqu'on regarde l'action de la Russie
République centrafricaine Mali ce sont
quand même deux pays sur lesquels on
peut montrer de manière très précise
quelles ont été les décisions françaises
qui ont créé les conditions d'un
affaiblissement de la de l'image de la
France et les conditions de renversement
d'alliance dans dans ces pays là et et
et dernier point sur la Chine euh là
aussi souvent et je pense que dans le
rapport d'information sur la relation la
France et l'Afrique on mentionne encore
beaucoup le fait que la Chine est
prédatrice et cetera bon oui euh bien
sûr la Chine est prédatrice mais à
nouveau les Africains vous répondront
que ce ne sont pas les seuls et que
historiquement la Belgique en République
démocratique du Congo la France dans des
pays d'Afrique centrale et d'Afrique de
l'Ouest on peut aussi quand même estimer
qui a eu de la prédation donc je crois
que aujourd'hui les Africains réalisent
que dans ces relations il faut euh qui
définissent un espace de défense de
leurs propres intérêts qui sont très
faibles dans la capacité à défendre ses
intérêts mais qu'il faut aujourd'hui
quand même essayer de défendre au mieux
euh les intérêts des des des des pays
africains et que par rapport à la Chine
on peut pas remettre en cause le fait
que la croissance de la Chine ses
besoins a joué un rôle important
également dans le le progrès euh
aujourd'hui des infrastructures dans
beaucoup de pays africains on est
conscient des des des grands travers de
de de l'investissement chinois euh mais
mais à nouveau on peut pas remettre en
cause le fait que sur 20 sur les 20
dernières années ou les 15 dernières
années l'entrée de la Chine a joué un
rôle important aussi dans l'amélioration
des conditions économiques sur le
continent à travers les infrastructures
et à travers également la hausse des
prix des des matières premières merci la
parole est à Karim
Bitar merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais rebondir à sur plusieurs
remarques il y en a deux qui me semblent
très intéressantes et qui sont
complémentaires l'une de l'autre le
représentant de la France insoumise
s'est demandé si c'était un ressentiment
contre la France elle-même ou contre
certaines politiques menées par la
France et le représentant des
républicains a posé une question
également très pertinente à savoir si
c'était l'Occident qui était globalement
contesté s'il y avait un ressentiment
particulier contre la
France ah je crois qu'on vous a perdu à
à Beyrouth
euh h alors bon on me signalera quand on
vous aura
retrouvé et peut-être qu'on va donc
passer directement aux questions
suivantes sauf si le le lien est coupé
hein donc ok donc on on va prendre la la
question suivante donc pour le groupe
démocrate la parole est à Sabine Tiley
oui ah non non allez B
vas-y c'était pas comm bon ben merci
beaucoup pour vos interventions on a on
a beaucoup parlé en fait ma question
rejoint un petitu peu aussi la question
de mon collègue JeanLouis tiriot on a
beaucoup parlé de la relation la France
avec Les Afriques on peut j'ai envie de
dire ça aussi mais pas particulièrement
de la relation Union
européenne pays africain est-ce qu'il y
a une différence comment est vu dans les
différentes parties de l'Afrique l'Union
européenne en tant que tel euh par
rapport à son positionnement quand même
de l'aide au développement mais
aussi maintenant par rapport à des
questions de sécurité et surtout aussi
par rapport aux questions de
l'immigration merci merci chers collègu
que alors on me dit que Monsieur bar est
r on a bien voilà on a bien noté la
question de notre collègue concernant le
la relation entre l'Union européenne et
l'Afrique alors on revient juste
précédemment maintenant qu'on vous a
retrouvé donc pour les réponses aux
précédentes questions oui pour clôturer
sur cette question je dirais que si le
ressentiment de la France semble plus
élevé c'est précisément parce qu'il y
avait des attentes qui étaient très
forte parce que la France nous avait
donné l'habitude à travers son histoire
de faire entendre un son de cloche
discordant par rapport à ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui l'Occident collectif
la voix de la France celle qui avait été
portée par le général de Gaulle
consistait justement à prendre en
considération les aspiration non pas
uniquement des Occidentaux mais du reste
du monde en 2003 lorsque la France de
jaces shirac et Dominique de Villepin se
sont élevés contre la guerre l'invasion
illégale de l'Irak jamais le soft power
de la France n'a été aussi euh fort
aussi présent en Afrique en Asie au
Moyen-Orient et même chez une grande
partie des citoyens américains et
aujourd'hui on note que même aussi bien
monsieur Trump au au parti républicain
que l'écrasante majorité des démocrates
sont d'accord pour dire que la France
avait su jouer le le rôle qui devait
être le sien de rappeler l'importance du
multilatéralisme de refuser que l'on
déclenche des guerres et des
interventions de façon débridée sans
prendre la vie du Conseil de sécurité
des Nations unies donc quand la France
ne met pas son drapeau dans sa poche
quand elle est fidèle aux valeurs qui
sont les siennes la France est acceptée
et au contraire il y a une demande de
France il y a un désir de France par
contre dès lors que la France semble
s'éloigner de cette mission des grands
idéau de la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen il est naturel que
les opinions publiques dans le Sud se
montrent particulièrement critique car
ils ont le sentiment qu'il y a une sorte
d'hypocrisie que la France trahit ses
propres valeurs donc ce n'est pas tant
la réelle politique qui pourrait faire
perdre ce n'est pas tant les grands
principes qui pourrait faire perdre à la
France son rôle et sa présence dans le
sud global c'est au contraire lorsqu'au
nom de certains intérêts géopolitiques
mal compris elle s'éloigne de ses grands
idéaux ça me permet de rebondir sur la
question très pertinente du représentant
des républicains qui se demandait si ce
n'était pas un vœux pieux aujourd'hui de
continuer de parler de démocratie et de
libéralisation alors en effet le
contexte international euh montre à
l'échelle planétaire un retour des
nationalismes autoritaires un euh refus
des valeurs des lumières un retour il y
a même certains sociologues qui ont
théorisé l'idée qu'il y a une demande
despotique une soif d'autoritarisme mais
je pense que nous sommes là dans une
vague liée aux angoisses suscité par la
mondialisation que cette vague ne sera
que temporaire et que si l'on souhaite
véritablement ancrer une relation solide
entre la France et les pays du Sud de la
Méditerranée ce n'est qu'en poussant
malgré toutes les difficultés actuelles
au maintien de la démocratie et des
idéos libéraux que l'on pourra être
fidèle à notre mission historique et si
même dans un pays comme la tun Tunisie
qui dispose de classe moyenne aussi
forte aussi éduquée de syndicats de
travailleurs de féministes d'avocats on
a été incapable de préserver cette
transition démocratique ce n'est pas
parce qu'il y avait dans la société
tunisienne une aspiration à au retour à
la dictature c'est aussi parce que quand
il y a eu ces dérives du président
actuel il n'y a pas eu suffisamment de
voix en Europe et en Occident pour lui
faire comprendre que les temps avaient
changé et qu'on ne pouvait plus revenir
à la px période des années 60 70 où un
pouvoir personnel totalement arbitraire
pouvait s'exercer donc c'est un effort
qui doit être fait des deux côtés certes
les défis sont innombrables certes le
nationalisme autoritaire a le vent en
poupe mais si l'on crée cet effet de
levier cette jonction entre les
jeunesses assoifffé de changement du Sud
et des politique européennees qui
resteraient fidèle à leurs principes aux
valeurs françaises à la ligne
golomérandienne et aussi aux valeurs de
l'Union européenne qui sont elles aussi
bafoué parfois de jour en jour quand on
entend certaines déclaration de Madame
vanon derleen par exemple si on restait
fidèle à nos principes issus de la
Révolution française des idéos des
droits de l'homme et des valeurs
européennes il n'y a aucune raison pour
que ce ressentiment français ne se tasse
pas s'il y a un dépit vis-à-vis de la
France c'est un dépits amoureux c'est
parce qu'on aime la France qu'on croit
dans les valeurs qui ont été portées par
des intellectuel français et qu'on a le
sentiment parfois que même en France
même en Europe certains pensent que cela
n'est plus à l'ordre du jour et on
revient à la pensée qui a précédé les
lumières on accepte de nouveau
l'inacceptable au nom euh de la réale
politique de la géopolitique et des
intérêts économiques mal compris je
pense pour préserver la stabilité de ces
sociétés et le développement économique
à long terme il est indispensable de
pousser également pour une certaine dose
de libéralisme politique car on ne peut
que tempement que temporairement
concilier l'autoritarisme et le
développement économique c'est possible
ça a été possible en Amérique latine
pendant une dizaine une vingtaine
d'années mais à long terme le
développement économique ne peut-être
péren que s'il se conjugue avec une
justice sociale et avec un libéralisme
politique bien merci pour cette réponse
on a bien noté la première question la
2uxè salle de notre collègue Sabine til
concernant la relation entre l'Union
européenne et l'Afrique et comme
monsieur c'est vous qui commencerz à
répondre comme on inverse l'ordre
pourvez nous dire finalement quelle
articulation entre cette volonté d'une
voix singulière de la France et en même
temps la nécessité de développer cette
relation entre l'Europe et et l'Afrique
et et comment on fait pour que tout ça
soit complémentaire et pas
contradictoire pour la deuxième question
pour le groupe socialiste la parole est
à Mélanie tomin merci monsieur le
Président merci messieurs pour votre
exposé chers collègues avec le groupe
socialiste nous avons reçu le 12 juillet
dernier les on composant le collectif
France Sael qui nous alertait déjà 2
semaines avant le coup d'État au Niger
sur les risques d'une présence et d'une
coopération uniquement militaire de la
France au Sahel ils évoquaient le fait
qu'une présence physique de la France
uniquement incarné par des militaires
d'abord dans le cadre de l'opération
barkane puis sans aucun cadre à la fin
de celle-ci créer une défiance certaines
chez les populations civiles à notre
égard il demandait au contraire que soit
développé rapidement de Solid programme
de coopération internationale en lien
avec la société civile autour de l'aide
au développement bien sûr mais pas
uniquement il devait aussi concerner
tous les autres domaines comme la
culture les arts la science la
francophonie l'économie le sport
également et bien d'autres sujets encore
pour construire des relations d'égal à
égal entre la France et les pays du
Sahel je sais que vous avez déjà répondu
en partie à cette question mais je
souhaitais connaître vos opinions à ce
sujet et en particulier la vôtre
monsieur monsieur Yabi qui représentait
la société civile avec votre s tank je
souhaitais aussi savoir comment
construire aujourd'hui des relations
plus équilibré entre la France et le
Sahel dans un contexte postcoup d'État
au Niger et puis j'aimerais appuyer la
question qu'a posé tout à l'heure mon
collègue notamment sur la question des
des partenariats économiques avec la
Chine par exemple mais aussi avec la
Russie et je voulais tout
particulièrement appuyer sur la question
du rapport à la ressource et au bien
commun euh est-ce que ce rapport à la
ressource évolue au sein des pays
africains quel regard la société civile
porte-t-elle sur l'exploitation de ces
ressources par les puissances
économiques étrangères je vous remercie
merci pour le groupe horison la parole
est à Anne leenonf merci monsieur le
Président merci messieur pour vos propos
introductifs très très intéressants euh
comme cela a été évoqué donc notre
commission débute aujourd'hui ainsi que
d'audition dédié à l'Afrique et cela
tombe bien si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
puisque mardi prochain en séance
publique à à l'Assemblée nationale aura
lieu une une déclaration du gouvernement
relative au partenariat renouvelé entre
la France et les pays africains suivi
d'un débat j'aurai l'honneur d'ailleurs
à cette occasion de m'exprimer au nom du
groupe horizon le président de la
République dans son discours du 27
février dernier a appelé à l'humilité et
à la responsabilité en dressant un bilan
de l'action française vis-à-vis des pays
africains à cette occasion il a
également tenté de définir une nouvelle
approche de la politique africaine de la
France davantage axé sur un partenariat
avec l'ensemble du continent partenariat
qui se déclinerait dans divers secteurs
tels que l'économie la culture le sport
ou encore les questions sécuritaires on
le sait il nous faut construire une
nouvelle relation équilibrée réciproque
responsable avec les pays africains et
la stratégie annoncée repose sur trois
piliers la présence militaire les
partenariat renouvelés et la jeunesse
vous l'avez également noté lors de votre
intervention monsieur banga la
diplomatie parlementaire faire jouera
j'en suis absolument convaincu un rôle
essentiel c'est pourquoi un groupe de
parlementaires d'ailleurs souhaitant
s'investir sur ce
sujet s'est engagé dans un groupe
spécifique dédié aux relations avec
l'Afrique dont je fais partie j'en suis
ravi je suis très confiante pour ma part
en notre capacité à proposer des actions
et une nouvelle voie d'être et de faire
nous en avons l'envie la première
question que je vais vous poser c'est
peut-être la plus difficile pour d'y
répondre ce sera mais est-ce réciproque
en avez-vous envie aussi est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est envisageable ou est-ce
que l'envie n'est pas partagé ça c'est
ma première question et la deuxième ce
sera sur les partenariats en tant que
tel quels sont selon vous les
partenariats prioritaires sur quoi
pouvons-nous finalement avancer en
priorité afin de nous faire gagner du
temps de le faire bien plutôt que de
nous disperser et quels en sont les
enjeux les obstacles
éventuellement et s'il y en a si vous
pouvez les part partager avec nous ce
serait
sympathique merci alors je vous propose
de prendre les deux questions
complémentaires pour que vous ayez plus
de temps pour répondre la parole est à
Giselle
lelouis merci monsieur le Président
messieur merci de vous exposé sur la
situation actuelle en Afrique par vos
exposés vous avez en partie répondu à
nos préoccupations ma question vous est
adressé à tous les trois devant cette
commission le chef d'état-major des
armées françaises appelé à voir
totalement la politique de la France en
Afrique notre pays est confronté à un
sentiment hostile voire une haine qui
semble croissante sur le continent
notamment dans les pays francophones
cette hostilité n'est pas le seul fait
de la propagande étrangère notamment
russe le président Macron qui entendait
renouveler les relations avec le
continent est dans une impasse et les
retraits successifs des troupes
françaises attestent de son échec
criayant aussi nous sommes très
intéressés par vos regard sur la
perception de la politique de la France
dans les pays francophones pouvez-vous
nous détailler les raisons de ce
sentiment antifrançais dans les sociétés
civiles comme au sein de régime
désormais hostiles par quel chemin selon
vous la France pourra-t-elle renouveler
en profondeur et N et pas et non pas
seulement en façade sa politique en
Afrique je vous remercie merci la parole
est à Delphine
ingeman merci monsieur le Président euh
comme ce cette audition est consacrée
aux sociétés en Afrique je voudrais moi
vous parler des femmes des femmes
africaines qui représentent la moitié de
la population du continent elles jouent
un rôle central dans le développement de
l'Afrique elles ont également un impact
significatif dans de nombreux domaines
tels que l'éducation les soins de santé
l'agriculture l'entrepreneuriat ou
encore la politique euh toutefois elles
sont encore confrontés un de nombreux
obstacles euh qui les empêchent d'être
pleinement impliqués d'avoir un impact
sur le développement de la Afrique sur
le volet d' l'éducation les hommes et
les femmes ne sont toujours pas euh
égaux en Afrique sur le volet du
développement économique les femmes
africaines stimulent la croissance
économique crée des opportunités
d'emploi encourage l'innovation mais peu
sont à des fonctions de direction de
gouvernance au sein des entreprises
autre enjeu la santé des femmes qui
représente un un aspect essentiel du
développement de l'Afrique
l'amélioration de l'accès à des services
de santé de qualité et notamment au
droit en matière de procréation aux
soins de santé maternelle est essentiel
pour le bien-être des femmes et le
progrès sociétal en en général et enfin
la participation à la vie politique des
femmes à la vie politique est-elles
aussi est-elle aussi cruciale pour
favoriser des processus décisionnels
inclusifs et un développement durable
alors membres de la délégation aux
droits des femmes j'aimerais recueillir
votre analyse sur la place des femmes en
Afrique leur contribution au
développement de leur pays sur la
diversité des situations selon les zones
du continent africain et une dernière
question un petit peu plus
peut-être spécifique quel rôle selon
vous joue la religion sur cette place
des femmes au sein des sociétés
africaines et dernière question selon
vous comment la France peut-elle
accompagner au mieux les femmes à
prendre toute leur place au sein des
sociétés africaines je vous remercie et
bien merci à toutes les cinq pour ces
cinq questions donc pour y répondre on a
euh une trentaine de minutes donc si
vous le souhaitez vous pouvez y répondre
en prenant jusqu'à 10 minutes et on va
prendre donc l'ordre inverse et donc la
parole est à Karim bitard qui est
notamment attendu sur l'articulation
entre ce que peut faire l'Union
européenne et aussi l'attente d'une voie
singulière de de la France comment
conjuguer les deux
euh merci monsieur le Président cette
question est véritablement extrêmement
pertinente je pense qu'il y a un désir
de France et qu'il y a un désir d'Europe
nous n sommes dans un monde qui est
marqué par une hégémonie américaine et
une montée en puissance de la Chine donc
face à ce G2 face à ce monde
américanoch-chinois qui est en train de
se
dessiner pour que la France puisse faire
entendre cette voix il faut qu'elle
s'exprime à travers euh ses relations
privilégiées avec les autres pays
européens et éventuellement aussi en
bâtissant des ponts avec les pays au sud
de la Méditerranée et en Afrique mais à
mes yeux le préalable
à ce que cette voix de la France puisse
se faire entendre en Europe et dans le
reste du monde c'est que cette voix de
la France ne devienne pas la réplique
exacte des autres discours occidentaux
depuis le début de la guerre à Gaza
beaucoup d'intellectuels du Maghreb
jusqu'au golf ont le sentiment que plus
rien ne distingue la voie de la France
de la voie d'un autre pays occidental la
Grande Bretagne les États-Unis ou les
autres et cela est quelque chose de
véritablement nouveau il y avait cette
endance qui avait commencé il y a une
dizaine d'années depuis 2007 plus
précisément mais aujourd'hui ça devient
euh véritablement difficile de euh euh
remarquer les nuances entre la position
française et les autres celles des
autres pays occidentaux même si le
président Macron a quelque peu marqué
une inflexion dans ces deux dernières
interventions en disant qu'il fallait
commencer à œuvrer pour un cesser le feu
en dénonçant les bombardements contre
les femmes et les enfants mais ce qui a
marqué notre partie du monde ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le sud global et
quelqu'un la personne qui a dit que
c'était une expression à prendre avec
des pincettes avait tout à fait raison
mais on se comprend on parle du sud de
l'Afrique de l'Amérique latine de l'Asie
du Sud-Est ce qui a fait euh la force de
la diplomatie dans la dans le passé de
la diplomatie française c'est qu'on ont
donnit l'impression d'avoir entendu les
voies du Sud le général de Gaulle était
un allié fidèle des États-Unis ce qui ne
l'a pas empêché de de s'opposer à eux
fermement dans son discours de Pnom Pen
en dénonçant par exemple la politique au
Vietnam en
1967 lors de la guerre des 6 jours le
général de Gaulle avait eu des propos
prophétiques il avait dit que
l'occupation de territoire l'annexion de
territoire par la force allait créer une
occupation cette occupation allait faire
naître une résistance résistance qu'
allait être qualifié de terrorisme et
que on nallait pas sortir de ce cercle
vicieux si on acceptait ce principe
d'annexion de territoire par la force si
on ne revenait pas au principe fondateur
du droit international donc cette voix
je sais bien que les temps ont changé
depuis 1967 je sais bien que le monde
est infiniment plus complexe mais euh il
y a quand même un capital de sympathie
que la France avait accumulé au f au fil
des ans depuis les positions du général
de Gaulle jusqu'à celle du refus de la
guerre en Irak et il ne faut pas laisser
ce capital de sympathie stiolé donc une
fois qu'on aura fait entendre à mes yeux
un son de cloche pas forcément en
opposition avec celui de la famille
occidentale mais un tout petit peu
discordant c'est-à-dire d'introduire les
nuances nécessaires de prendre en
considération le ressenti des peuples du
Sud le facteur de l'humiliation le
facteur
euh historique la France est un pays qui
a produit tellement d'intellectuels
tellement d'historiens et la mieux placé
pour pour contextualiser les événements
ce qui se passe au Moyen-Orient n'a pas
commencé le 7 octobre il y a des
décennies qui ont précédé marqué par des
répressions brutales des occupations des
colonisations donc c'est le rôle de la
France que de revenir à cette ligne
historique qui a été marqué par le
tournant Gauliste dans les années 60
mais qui s'est prolongé dans une large
mesure avec Valérie giscardestin avec
François mitteran de faire entendre un
son de cloche discordant et ensuite de
chercher des partenariats avec les pays
européens qui sont plus ou moins sur la
même ligne et ensemble la France et
l'Europe pourront véritablement influer
à ce moment-là sur les États-Unis
d'Amérique car les États-Unis d'Amérique
ont eux aussi besoin d'intermédiairees
puissant construire des ponts avec le
reste du monde
euh donc à mes yeux ce sentiment
anti-rançais n'est en rien dû à un rejet
des idéaux de la France à un rejet de ce
que la France représente c'est au
contraire une déception de voir la
France être parfois elle-même infidèle à
certains grands principes au nom de la
protection d'intérêt économique au nom
de la nécessité de maintenir une
stabilité à court terme d'éviter des
vagues migratoires et cetera donc si la
France ne met pas son drapeau dans sa
poche si elle continue à faire entendre
sa voix lorsque les circonstances
l'exigent elle se retrouvera
considérablement renforcée au sein même
de l'Europe et particulièrement elle
trouvera énormément d'éch favorbl en
Afrique et ailleurs l'autre question
très importante c'est celle du rôle des
femmes et lorsqu'on parle de l'Afrique
du Nord c'est quelque chose de
véritablement décisif si ces révolutions
arabes de 2011 ont pu être aussi
marquantes ont pu être un véritable
tournant ont pu marquer une rupture
épistémologique c'est parce qu'elles
étaient en grande partie des révolutions
menées avec ou pas des femmes ce sont
des mouvements syndicalistes des
mouvements féministes tunisiens des
universitaires femmes qui ont été à
l'avant-garde de ce mouvement et ce qui
était significatif c'est que ces femmes
s'efforcé de conjuguer le combat
nationaliste le combat contre les
régimes autoritaires et dictatoriaux
avec le combat pour une émancipation
sociale et économique et une
émancipation notamment des femmes la
Tunisie avait av un long historique
c'est l'un des premiers pays à avoir euh
donné à la
femme la pilule contreceptive 10 ans
avant la France c'est également un pays
qui a autorisé l'avortement dès 1965 en
Tunisie Habib bourgiba donc 10 ans avant
la loi veê en France donc il y a un long
une longue histoire un
héritage de qui consiste à donner le
pouvoir aux femmes mais lorsque les
femmes prennent ce pouvoir elles peuvent
faire basculer ces sociétés il y a un
risque parfois cela dit à prendre en
considération c'est celui de la mise en
place d'une sorte de féminisme d'État
c'est-à-dire où on dirait la l'épouse du
président de la République madame
Benali va elle-même patronner la
question des droits des femmes et cetera
et là ça peut-être extraordinairement
contreproductif le modèle auquel il faut
revenir c'est le modèle qui a émergé en
Égypte dans dans les années 20
lorsqu'une femme admirable qui
s'appelait Hoda sharaoui euh s'est
installée sur la place Tahrir du CER en
1923 a arraché son voile elle a dit je
veux être féministe je veux être
journaliste elle a créé et contribué
à au lancement de plusieurs grands
journaux notamment de langue française
elle a créé l'Union des femmes arabes on
était 5 ans avant la naissance des
Frères musulmans si les Frères musulmans
sont montés en puissance c'est parce
qu'ils étaient en train de réagir à la
percée de ces mouvements libéraux
démocratiques féministes progressistes
dans cette partie du monde donc il y a
un historique extrêmement important dans
lequel on pourrait puiser l'historique
de ce qu'on appelle la Nahda la
Renaissance arabe dès la moitié du 19e
siècle le milieu du 19e siècle de grands
intellectuels hommes et femmes ont mis
cette question au centre la question de
la citoyenneté et de l'égalité des
droits entre les hommes et les femmes
bout Rossel Boustani était un grand
intellectuel libanais qui a dit que
c'est par la citoyenneté et par
l'émancipation des femmes que viendrait
le libéralisme et la démocratie dans le
monde arabe donc c'est un effet à
travers ce levier que doit se mener le
combat politique à condition d'éviter
toutes sortes de de de récupération
politique et vous avez ajouté une
question subsidiaire qui est très
importante et quel est le rôle de la
religion alors en est effet on a
tendance en Occident à percevoir ces
sociétés comme étant monolithique à
penser que parce qu'il y a des courants
islamoonservateur très présent le rôle
des femmes sera par définition marginal
or on peut s'appuyer sur l'histoire pour
dire qu'il y a à côté de ces courants
islamo-conservateurs des courants
libéraux et progressistes qui ont
insister sur le rôle que doivent jouer
les femmes et à l'intérieur même des
mouvements islamo conservateur il y a
des femmes qui se servent de certaines
interprétations du Coran pour dire aux
hommes euh la vision matchiste
patriarcal que vous nous imposez elle ne
vient pas des textes religieux eux-mêmes
au contraire les textes religieux
étaient une avancée par rapport à ce
qu'il y avait avant c'est vous les
hommes et notamment l'interprétation
qu'on a donné à certains versets du
Coran et à certains hadiths qui vous ont
permis de perpétuer la domination
masculine donc aujourd'hui si on
s'appuie à la fois sur celle qui issu du
contexte
islamoconservateur lutte pour une
émancipation des femmes en s'appuyant
sur certains versets plus progressiste
euh du Coran ou sur certains hadis
favorbles à l'émancipation des femmes et
d'un autre côté dans le camp laïque
surtout les progressistes et les
libéraux je pense que nous pourrons
construire une sorte de courant assez
significatif qui ne sera pas majoritaire
pour être honnête nous n'aurons pas 50 %
de la population aujourd'hui dans les
pays d'Afrique du Nord qui serait
entièrement favorable à ce qui avaiit
été voté en Tunisie une constitution
permettant l'égalité totale des droits
et des devoirs qui reconnaissaiit
l'égalité et non pas la complémentarité
les islamistes avaient initialement
essayé de remplacer le mot égalité
homme-femme par le mot complémentarité
le parti islamo-conservateur en Nahda
mais parce qu'il y a eu une forte
mobilisation de la société civiles des
féministes ils ont finalement accepté et
la Constitution qui avait été votée en
Tunisie était l'une des plus libérales
euh instaurer la liberté de conscience
le droit de changer de religion
l'égalité hommees-femme et c'est donc
c'est un peu pour ça que je disais tout
à l'heure que ce fut une grande erreur
que d'accepter un peu trop facilement ce
retour en arrière et de permettre à
Monsieur Kais said l'actuel président
tunisien de revenir sur ces énormes
acquis qui furent ceux de la décennie
d'ouverture démocratique cette
transition qui a été tumultueuse mais
qui a quand même é une parenthèse dans
laquelle on pourra puiser à l'avenir
merci beaucoup pour cette cette
intervention et cette réponse très très
complète je vais passer la parole
désormais à à gilabi qui va notamment
nous dire si pour répondre à notre
collègue Leen si il y a une envie
également des des Africains de de
d'accentuer de renouveler cette cette
coopération merci beaucoup pour les pour
les nouvelles
questions alors je vais peut-être
commencer par par celle-là effectivement
est-ce qu'il y a une envie d'abord je
pense qu'on on l'a dit mais peut-être
pas suffisamment vraiment tenir compte
de la
diversité des pays africains dont on
parle évidemment la relation de la
France avec les pays euh qui furent ses
anciennes colonies est très différente
de celle de la France avec les les
autres pays africains et d'ailleurs
depuis de nombreuses années et je dirais
c'est de bonne guerre côté français il y
a une diversif iication de ces
partenariats euh un investissement plus
important vers des pays comme l'Afrique
du Sud bon le Nigéria depuis très
longtemps mais aussi le Mozambique où il
y a aussi des ressources naturelles
importantes donc euh euh je crois que si
on se ressemble sur la relation avec les
les pays qui ont eu des relations
particulières au cours des dernières
décennies où on a une phase de de de
tension euh oui je pense qu'il y a une
envie de de de de continuer et de
changer les les les partenariats mais je
crois qu'il y a élément quand même où il
y a deux éléments importants euh à
souigner le premier c'est que euh il
faut tenir compte des de la
hiérarchisation des des priorités euh du
côté du côté africain on a euh lorsqu'on
regarde les statistiques de
développement économique et social des
statistiques d'accès à l'énergie que je
mentionnais tout à l'heure euh et
lorsqu'on regarde la capacité des États
en terme de fonctionnairees en terme de
budget euh euh il y a des choix
prioritaires qui doivent être faits euh
euh et y compris euh dans le temps qu'on
va accorder à la discussion la
négociation des partenariats extérieur
et le temps qu'on doit consacrer au
renforcement des bases institutionnelles
économiques sociales des des pays
africains euh et donc d'une certaine
manière lorsqu'on regarde juste le flux
de réunions international diverses euh
et varié euh en fait le ce que cela
coûte en terme de temps pour les
ressources humaines euh de cette des
pays africains est beaucoup plus
important que c que ce que cela coûte
euh pour un pays comme la France ou pour
l'Union européenne avec ces ces milliers
de de de fonctionnaires et je crois que
c'est un élément peut-être qui semble
euh anecdotique mais en fait qui est
absolument central euh on a besoin de
réussir à se concentrer sur les
priorités euh structurelles des pays
africains de définir des les l'espace
qui implique des partenariats extérieurs
et le deuxième élément c'est que ces
partenariats extérieurs ils sont divers
aujourd'hui le monde a changé donc euh
il y a une volonté de maintenir
d'approfondir des partenariats avec la
France comme avec l'Allemagne comme avec
d'autres pays européens mais comme avec
la Chine avec les les pays du golf et
cetera exactement comme la France le
fait et comme toutes les grandes les
moyennes et les petites puissances et
les nonpuissances le font également donc
je crois que le peut-être le risque
c'est de considérer que le fait pour les
pays africains de diversifier leurs
parten arat consiste nécessairement à à
à à donner un message négatif à la
France il s'agit simplement à nouveau
d'une nouvelle phase historique euh sur
le le le Sahel également spécifiquement
je pense que euh madame la députée a a
mentionné justement ces relations
tendues avec le le le Sahel euh et les
pays qui ont connu des coups d'État
récemment je voudrais juste dire que euh
il y a un élément sur les les coups
d'État euh euh qui qui qui est qui est
très clair lorsqu'on regarde l'exemple
du nigère tout récent euh on voit quand
même que une chose est de dénoncer des
coups d'État militairees et c'est tout à
fait normal c'est conforme cette
dénonciation est conforme aux règles au
protocoles que la région ouest-aricaine
notamment s'est donné les protocoles de
la CDAO euh mais en même temps une autre
chose est de décider de quelle sanction
on met en place et de décidé de menacer
d'une intervention militaire euh dans ce
cas on a quand même eu des déclarations
au plus haut niveau français sur le
soutien à une éventuelle intervention
militaire de la CDAO et je cite quand
elle le décidera et je crois que ce type
de message euh extrêmement dévastateur
pour la perception euh des des sahéliens
et des Africains de manière générale sur
euh justement aujourd'hui la lecture de
la France du du rapport qu'elle doit
avoir dans le fond et dans la forme euh
une intervention militaire au Niger
qu'on soit contre le coup d'état euh je
pense que lorsqu'on connaît la région on
ne peut pas soutenir on pouvait pas
soutenir l'idée d'une intervention
militaire au Niger euh parce
qu'évidemment c'est trop risqué qu'on a
eu beaucoup d'interventions qui ont
quand même produit des résultats
catastrophiques pour l'ensemble de la
région et je crois que ce type de
positionnement a réellement desservi euh
et peut-être de manière assez durable
justement la perception de la de la
politique française dans cette régionlà
qui mais cette relation peut être
construite euh elle va être construite
notamment euh si on a aussi un
changement à nouveau dans le fond et
dans la forme euh euh lorsqu'on
s'adresse au aux pays africains
euh sur la la question euh peut-être de
de l'Europe euh de la perception
européenne
euh là aussi euh deux ou trois points le
premier c'est que oui les les Africains
enfin la parti euh qui est très
minoritaire en réalité qui s'intéresse à
ce type de de question euh ben voit
l'action de l'Union européenne en tant
qu'acteur de financement du
développement euh des infrastructures et
et dans beaucoup d'autres domaines mais
elle voit aussi beaucoup euh le débat
continue sur la migration la question de
la migration je pense est centrale aussi
euh dans la la formation euh de la
vision que les les beaucoup d'Africains
ont de de de l'Europe et cette vision
c'est celle d'une Europe qui euh
considère que sa priorité absolue c'est
la lutte contre l'immigration régulière
et que euh et au fond euh il y a pas
vraiment de problème pour avoir des
dispositifs de sélection des des talents
lorsqu'on a des penuies dans le domaine
des personnels de santé dans les pays
pas seulement européens d'ailleurs aux
États-Unis c'est la même chose on met en
place des mécanismes pour pouvoir
attirer des médecins des infirmiers et
cetera euh mais en même temps euh au
fond on veut on veut on veut trier on
veut sélectionner et et je crois que euh
cette euh cette cette perception est est
forcément négative parce qu'elle ne
tient pas compte de la longue histoire
des migrations qui ont concerné aussi
l'Europe pendant très longtemps et le le
le l'autre élément par rapport à la
migration c'est que même des fingank
européen nous hawati on collabore avec
l'Institut Jacques de l'or on a organisé
des discussions sur cette question
migratoire euh cet institut a publié
l'année dernière un rapport avec des
pistes précises sur des visas de
circulation des visas de travail qui
permettrai de Ben de d'ouvrir beaucoup
plus de voies pour des migrations
régulières qui sont d'ailleurs souvent
des migrations temporaires de
circulation et donc lorsqu'on regarde
les milliers de morts en Méditerranée il
y a une responsabilité de la part des
pays de départ sur le manque
d'amélioration des conditions
économiques des jeunes mais en même
temps il y a aussi une responsabilité de
la part des politiques qui ferment en
fait les voies les voies les voies
légales lorsque les jeunes ont la
certitude qu'ils ne peuvent pas avoir de
visa ils n'auront pas de visa lorsqu'ils
déposeront leur dossier évidemment ils
n'envisagent même pas la possibilité
d'une migration qui soit qui soit légal
qui soit qui soit régulière donc je
pense que cette question migratoire
reste probablement l'élément déterminant
minant dans la vision assez négative que
beaucoup d'Africains ont de de de
l'Union européenne le dernier élément
par rapport à l'Europe c'est que euh
aujourd'hui je crois que la la il y a
une polarisation sur la France et une
distinction entre la France et les
autres pays européens et on voit
d'ailleurs aussi qu'il y a une forme
d'autonomisation de l'Allemagne et de
quelques autres pays européens dans leur
lecture de la situation en Afrique de
l'Ouest et dans le Sahel euh et le
sentiment ben que justement euh il est
important aujourd'hui d'avoir une
politique de l'Union européenne qui ne
se réduisent pas à celle de des
États-membres et de quelques
États-membres et il y a aussi de la part
des États-membres à nouveau chacun
défend ses intérêts et et et l'Allemagne
est beaucoup plus présente aujourd'hui
dans la région sahélienne également
dernier dernier il y avait une question
sur les sur les femmes alors de derniers
points je penseil me reste quelqu une
minute et demi euh sur les sur les
femmes c'est question extrêmement
importante je dois dire que d'abord nous
nous au niveau du Fing tank que que que
que que que nous animons euh ça fait
partie des questions centrales la
question de la participation économique
de la participation politique de la
place des femmes dans la société de la
vision de la place des femmes dans les
sociétés notamment ouestafricaines
euh les questions de système de santé
sont importantes vous avez mentionné la
question des soins de santé maternel
toutes ces questions sont fondamental
mais de mon point de vue elle doit faire
l'objet d'abord de débat public interne
dans les sociétés euh euh africaine euh
sur des questions de société et la
question de la place de la femme c'est
une question de société importante euh
je crois que on ne peut pas décider que
lorsqu'on a un progrès
ou en tout cas un changement important
euh décidé par le Parlement français ou
par un parlement d'un autre d'un autre
pays européen que tout de suite cela
doivent s'imposer euh dans des pays
africains il y a pas de raison à cela
parce parce qu'au fond l'évolution sur
ces sujets-là partout elle est le
résultat de bataillees internes de de de
parfois féocce de point de vue
différents donc sur la ces questions de
société ces sujets de société en Afrique
aussi on a besoin de débat public
informé sérieux constructif sur ces
questions-là euh mais je voudrais
souligner qu'il y a vraiment aussi euh
des progrès importants sur la paration
politique les pays africains quelques
pays africains sont aujourd'hui parmi
les tous premiers au niveau mondial en
terme de représentation des femmes dans
les parlements le Rwanda bien sûr mais
au Sénégal où je suis il y a quand même
une loi sur la parité qui
automatiquement a a induit non pas une
véritable 5 50 % 50 % mais presque euh
dans à l'Assemblée nationale on a aussi
des progrès dans des pays comme le Bénin
où des côas ont été mise en place donc
il y a quand même eu vraiment des
changements dans beaucoup de pays
africains pour améliorer la
représentation des femmes dans l'espace
politique et sur le plan économique
aussi il y a une multiplicité
d'initiatives parfois d'entrepreneurs
femmes NOTAM notamment pour accompagner
d'autres femmes financer des des
initiatives et je pense que ce que la
France peut faire c'est de manière
réaliste et avec une certaine humilité
accompagner lesistant accompagner les
initiatives de personnes qui font déjà
des choses et dans dans dans ces
domaineslà à nouveau mais en respectant
la nécessité je le disais déjà de débat
public interne qui vont faire évoluer
ces sociétés sur sur la la la place des
des des femmes tout dernier tout dernier
toute dernière mention en une minute
parce qu'elle est importante pour moi
c'est la question de la démocratie le
soutien à la démocratie oui mais je
crois que aujourd'hui lorsqu'on regarde
les sondages 66 % entre 66 et 70 % des
Africains sont systématiquement en
faveur de la démocratie comme étant le
meilleur système de gouvernement la
question ce n'est pas donc une remise en
cause du principe démocratique c'est une
dénonciation que les démocraties non
effectiv en fait qui sont des
démocraties factices ben ne produisent
aucun résultat sur le plan sécuritaire
sur sur le plan de l'amélioration du
bien-être économique et social donc
l'enjeu ce n'est pas démocratie ou pas
de démocratie l'enjeu c'est quel type de
démocratie comment est-ce qu'on
construit des démocraties substantielles
et comment est-ce qu'on construit des
états efficaces et je pense que ces deux
questions elles sont liées mais elles ne
sont pas identiques on a besoin d'État
on a besoin de politique publi et on a
besoin aussi de légitimité politique
passant par une démocratie qui ne se
réduiseent pas au processus électorauuxx
merci beaucoup bien merci pour cette
réponse et maintenant on a une dernière
réponse de Arthur manga qui a
la tâche difficile de répondre parce
qu'il y a déjà eu beaucoup de réponses
et en plus peut-être qu'on pourrait vous
demander un mot de de conclusion sur
finalement comment également de votre
côté vous avez ressenti cette cette
audition cet échange et quelles sont les
attentes finalement que vous pouvez
avoir sur nos travaux sur notre cycle
que que l'on va mener dans les dans les
prochaines semaines d'accord bah euh
déjà bon pour pour un peu changer pour
nous mettre un peu dans l'ambiance de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a quand même
quelques divergences entre Gil et moi
sur certains points par exemple sur le
point de l'intervention militaire moi je
soutenais que la France aide à
l'intervention militaire à partir du
moment où c'est la CDAO c'est une
décision africaine qui est prise et
qu'on peut soutenir parce que ce ce
discours de dit on est contre coup
d'taille on fait rien pour qu'il se
multiplie en Afrique moi je suis contre
et donc au bout d'un moment si ça passe
par une intervention militaire ciblée
qui peut être efficace par la
supériorité du feu justement euh oui
c'était bienvenu et malheureusement il y
a eu des hésitations et des
atémoirements aujourd'hui on a on a au
Niger une jeunte pour moi indigne qui
s'installe et et qui qui enracine la
pratique des coups d'État et souvent les
intellectuels africain ne sont pas assez
durs avec les jeunes sont plutôt forts
dans expliquer dans d'en trouver
pourquoi on peut l'entendre mais pour
moi euh non je pense que justement tant
que la réponse euh est harmonisée avec
les institutions africaines bah les
soutiens sont sont bienvenus euh dans ce
et je pense aussi qu'il faut pas pas
négliger hein
he la remise en cause même de la
démocratie je je pense qu'elle se remet
en cause euh ja dit tout à l'heure je
suis d'accord avec lui surtout en
niouveau intellectuel ça se pose pas
trop comme question mais dans la société
ça se pose de plus en plus en revanche
là je suis d'accord avec eu c'est sur
les raisons de cette remise en cause il
a une remise en cause de la démocratie
parce que justement certains par la
mauvaise application de la démocratie ne
trouve pas euh euh euh des résultats euh
euh effent et donc remettre en Cuse ce
principe c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui le
soutien à la démocratie le soutien aux
initiatives démocratiques est quelque
chose d'important et j'ai envie de dire
c'est un devoir pour la France qui qui
se positionne comme le pays de la
liberté le pays des droits de l'homme et
ça doit être le pays pour moi d'un point
de vue de de de de la conception de de
l'idéal et de l'idéologie qui doit
soutenir bien plus que ça euh les
démocraties les initiatives
démocratiques et les réformes
démocratiques qui sont pris sur le
continent pour qu'on aille plus loin euh
je vais revenir maintenant aux questions
à à quelquesun d' lui il y a la il y a
personnellement il y a la réciprocité
sinon je pense qu'on on on ne serait pas
pour moi par exemple avir faire 6000 km
pour je je pense quand même que c'est
c'est parce qu'on le souhaite et et avec
les autres maintenant euh c'est clair
que il y a toujours des extrémistes qui
vont vous dire non on n veut pas mais
même si non on nen veut pas je je pense
pas qu'il faut il soit profond euh il y
a une volonté il y a une réciprocité de
construire quelque chose avec avec tout
le monde d'abord avec tout le monde et
donc avec la France voilà
et ça je pense que tout le monde là et
et même les gens les plus les plus dures
vous diront toujours à la fin il faut
qu'on discute il faut qu'on construise
et et le collègue libana avait parlé
d'interdépendance du monde aujourd'hui
on peut pas construire un monde avec
certains acteurs donc sans l'Afrique
sans la France c'est pas possible faut
construire des choses ensemble en
revanche oui il y a des il y a des
faiblesses dans dans notre projet commun
eu la première faiblesse c'est notre
histoire notre histoire longue commune
partagée qui a aussi des ombres et
souvent j'ai envie de dire la position
face à ces
ombres on entend des choses souvent sur
la colonisation quand vous êtes africain
que vous les entendez vous vous dites
mais vraiment de quoi on parle on parle
de gens qui ont été privés qui ont
été privés de droit spolier et et face à
ces questions par exemple et d'autant
plus que ce ce modèle a réussi à
raffermir quelque peu les relations avec
des pays comme le Rwanda et donc faut
une mémoire commune assumer ce qui s'est
passé entre nous c'est quelque chose
d'assez important et de cette histoire
commune peut tomber sur certains
imaginaires qui sont mal construits de
partes et d'autres j'ai lu un livre
assez intéressant pourquoi l'Afrique est
rentré dans l'histoire sans nous dans
lequel on voit très bien que les
imaginaires sur l'Afrique que ce soit
dans la à la télévision au journal
télévisé
dans les chansons on a toujours des imag
négatifs qui déconstruisent donc
l'Afrique et c'est pour ça je pense dans
les recommandations du du somau de monpé
il y avait la la la la question de la
construction de la maison des monde
africain des diaspora pour mieux faire
apparaître mais de l'autre côté aussi on
on on on construit mal cet imaginaire
commun et et ça a des ça a des
conséquences je pense qu' il est temps
aussi de tenu compte euh des changements
euh de voir l'Afrique comme un véritable
espace géopolitique et plus comme un
précaré je parle surtout de l'Afrique
francophone un précaré ce serait un coin
qui nous est acquis dans lequel toute
concurrence est perçu comme rivalité
alors qu'il faut comprendre qu'on est
d'un véritable espace géopolitique voilà
où les rivalités les concurrences les
les coopérations vont se construire en
fonction de de des nécessités des
besoins voilà et justement euh euh il
faut donc en France qu'on accepte cette
concurrence qu'on accepte qu'il y a un
véritable que l'Afrique aujourd'hui un
véritable enjeu géopolitique sur quel il
faut se battre comme vous vous battez
pour avoir des marchés en Chine et même
souvent de vous en Allemagne mais il
faut cette même bataille avec les autres
acteurs sans sans ressentiment supérieur
avec des atouts avec des atouts que que
vous avez que nous avons ensemble dans
cette histoire il il y a du dur mais il
y a des atouts les diasporas hein la
culture la langue sont des atouts sur
lesquels on peut jouer pour construire
notre notre relation et quels sont les
domaines qui qui vont venir pour moi il
y a des écueils à balancer tout de suite
j'ai dit les deux principaux liens
historiquement de cette présence C
attachement en Afrique sont la monnaie
et la présenceitaire par le franc CFA
qui a réussi certaines choses qui par
exemple permet aux économies de Lie mois
de mieux résister aux crises d'avoir
plus de confiance mais il est temps de
passer un autre modèle qui soit accepté
tout en conservant justement les
réussites de de ce qui a été déjà fait
et et il faut avancer depuis Abidjan
2019 ça fait 4 ans il y a pas beaucoup
de chos que avancer sur ce domaine il y
a des réflexions qui soit assez
intéressante sur la présence militaire
parce que on parle de juste distance
donc pas de disparition donc faut faut
comprendre que la transformation des
bases militaires euh euh pour avoir plus
de formation plus de monté en puissance
à Abidjan on a le modèle de l'Académie
Internationale de lut contre terorisme
qui est un modèle assez intéressant
voilà qui sont des choses après tout ce
qui est autour du du du vivant et
surtout des humanités j'appelle par
humanité euh les questions de jeunesse
les échanges entre étudiants entre de
recherche les questions de culture moi
quand j'étais plus jeune dans mon lycée
avait un club Molière dans lequel on
apprenait la culture un peu de culture
française mais ça n'existe plus alors
que vous avez de plus en plus d'institut
confissus de club Canadiens donc faut
revivre par ça faut revivre par par ces
moyens qui par la culture par les
jeunesses par les échanges euh qui vont
permettre justement de de revivre et de
et de réarmer réarmer cette pensée faut
vivre par les sociétés civiles et c'est
très bien je vais garder ça peut-être
pour la fin mais c'est très intéressant
de de d'impliquer ces sociétés civil et
tout ça dans dans la réforme dans la
pensée il faudrait pas que ce soit une
pensée c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
construction de cette pensée
coconstruction de cet
avenir AFR frrançais qu'il faut la
question de l'aide est une question
assez importante parce que l'aide
d'abord le mot aide pour moi il est il
est un peu gênant parce qu'il ramène à
de la domination déjà euh à à à une
sorte de magnanimité ou voilà donc il
faut déjà le bannir mais il faut
rechercher aussi de l'efficacité voilà
euh de l'efficacité par par définir
ensemble les priorités par vérifier
l'efficacité ou ou les résultats qu'on
doit obtenir dans dans dans ces
partenariats qu'on peut avoir c'est très
important parce que certains mettent
moins j'ai envie de dire et gagnneent
plus en terme d'image et en terme de
résultat par rapport eu au Paris qu'on
peut mettre dans dans cette
collaboration les jeunesses les femmes
les femmes oui euh je l'a bien dit il y
a des progrès assez intéressants euh euh
dans dans nos pays mais reste encore des
défis importants sur la scolarisation
des femmes sur leur santé sur les mises
en place sur les les ce que font nos
sociétés civiles et d'ailleurs les
relations entre les différentes sociétés
civiles les partages expérience Nord
sudud ou même sud- sudud que ce soit
même en démocratie il y a des modèles de
démocratie Sud qui sont assez important
hein que qui peuvent être qui peuvent
être euh euh mis ensemble donc regarder
de face en commun notre histoire en
l'assumant en assumant dans ses dans ses
ombres dans ses lumières euh revenir ce
qui l'humanité qui peut nous accompagner
revenir sur la place des sociétés
civiles et essayer au mieux de
transformer en fonction des attentes
mais euh avec des valeurs claires les
valeurs de la liberté les valeurs de la
démocratie elles sont trop souvent
noyées par les intérêts géopolitiques
par les intérêts économiques aujourd'hui
on réfléchit par deux fois avant de
prendre une déclaration on réfléchit par
trois fois avant d'apporter son soutien
et enfin il faut de la cohérence je je
reviens sur la cohérence c'est très
important c'est très important de savoir
que euh il y a un cap sur qu'on suit
dans cette relation pour boucler et ça
ma présence ici et celle de Gil de Karim
par par vision c'est ce que nous
souhaitons pour deux raisons je luai dit
en début la meilleure représentation du
peuple c'est l'Assemblée nationale
finalement et donc quand l'Assemblée
nationale se saisit de ces débats ça
signifie que le peuple français sen
saisit et quand elle invite des
chercheurs des représentants de la
société civile c'est-à-dire qu'elle elle
va chercher le peuple hors mur et c'est
là qui doit être la force c'est ça qui
doit être notre différence c'est ça qui
va permettre de reconstruire parce que
trop longtemps la relation affro
française a été une relation personnelle
entre nos chefs d'État qui ont pris des
décisions plus dans les intérêts des
chefs d'État dans les intérêts de
certaines entreprises que dans les
intérêts des peuples il est important
que les peuples et les humanités
retrouvent leur place à la fois dans
l'intérêt mais dans le processus de
décision je le dis moi par exemple quand
je parle avec les gens du poste
d'Abidjan à sé de temps en temps dans
dans les débats les sociétés civiles les
entrepreneurs si qu'est-ce qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire de par exemple du
contrat de désendettement il faut pas
tout faire avec l'État oui il y a l'état
qui a qui a qui a qui a la meilleure
légitimité mais aussi il y a d'autres
acteurs qu'il faut privilégier qu'il
faut encourager je pense que
euh les acteurs africains la société
civile les chercheurs sont à disposition
la preuve Gile est là je suis là mais à
chaque fois que vous sererez sur des
terrains africains je pense que les gens
prendront beaucoup de plaisir à parler
avec vous et à dire avec peut-être
beaucoup plus de de de de désinvolture
au sens positif du thème que nous par
exemple en les trouvant chez eux mais il
faut qu'on le sente je suis tout à fait
content qu'aujourd'hui la question
devienne nationale à travers sa
représentation et j'espère que vos
travaux j'ai dit il y a une longue
tradition de rapport euh quand même de
l'Assemblée nationale et finalement
c'est assez livra c'est assez
intéressant mais j'espère que vos
travaux vont permett d'aller plus loin
que sur des rapports de paiser
réellement c'est vrai que pour les
questions de défense et de et de
relations internationales sont bâtis
comme des du précarré présidentiel mais
on voit depuis des années que
l'Assemblée nationale essaie de
grignoter essayez encore d'en grignoter
c'est c'est tant mieux pour nous et puis
essayer surtout de
paiser essayer surtout de piser de
prendre des décisions qui seront
positives et et pour l'ensemble de nos
peuples je pense qu'il y a un avenir je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous moi
je suis confiance dans l'avenir de nos
relations on a une phase de rupture qui
peut avoir ses turpitudes qui peut avoir
ces dangers je pense quand même que on a
on a beaucoup de lien par nos diaspora
par notre langue par par la beauté de
nos continents voilà et et et tout ça
par des gens qui qui sont issus de nos
de cet amour issus de cette culture qui
feront tout pour que vivent une
meilleure relation afro-française une
relation plus équilibré qui va permettre
à l'Afrique et à la France de continuer
leur long cheminement mais cette fois
dans un intérieur réciproque et dans le
winwin dansun vrai gagnant gagnant je
vous remercie c'est un plaisir pour moi
je pense pour mes deux collègues de
pouvoir échanger avec vous euh jour bien
mais écoutez merci à tous les trois pour
ce moment d'échange très riche qui
permet de lancer nos nos travaux et
j'espère qu'on arrivera chacun un peu
plus aiguisé pour le débat qui aura lieu
mardi prochain dans dans l'hémicycle
dans le cadre de de ce partenariat et
nous continuerons dès mercredi en
élargissant nos travaux à la commission
des finances sur la partie coopération
monétaire endettement et ensuite avec la
section française de la PF notamment
pour tous ces sujets culturels et de
francophonie donc vraiment encore une
fois merci à à tous les trois et donc
euh on continue nos nos travaux très
bonne journée à
tous merci
bientôt